В мене ще раночок, тому просто доброго дня.
Доброго дня.
Чи вітаю, вітаю всіх, вітаю.
Доєднаємося зараз всі.
Як настроєння, скажіть, будь ласка.
Як ви, як ваше настроєння? Раскажіть, де ви? Віжу хтось в дорогі. Уляна, лайк. Добрий вечір, вітаю. Вітаю, вітаю. Так, добре. Хтось в дорозі, хтось в кабінеті? Оксана, а ви де? Не віжу.
Доброго вечора, я тут. Две минуты у мені ще.
Всем привіт, привіт, привіт, привіт.
Мені, хто-то може подсказати, як я можу себе на айфоне переименувати,
тому що зуму, зуму, перший раз на телефоне захожу, я не знаю, как...
А ти прям нажмай на себе, де участники, нажимай на айфон, і там буде переименувати.
Ага, хорошо, спасибо. А то ще дому не добрано, спасибо.
Прямо я тоже так да.
Як ви себе чуваєте? Раскажіть, як готова? Вчора у вас була с'юлі с'юлі с'юлі, правильно? Менторське було занятие. Можете голосом відвичати.
Пару минут, присоединюся, нормально, бегу дому. Так, хорошо.
Смотрите, ми ці два дні будемо розбирати дуже важні теми.
Соответственно, для того, щоб розбирати ці важні теми,
ми вже зараз заходимо в цю роботу.
Уже з первих минути.
Почему?
Тому що перша тема у нас буде активне слушання.
Да, зараз ми перейдем на нашу презентацию.
Відно всім?
Так, так, видно, чудово.
Дякую.
Активне слухання на сьогодні важлива тема.
А завтра – збереження присутності.
Тож, ми вже зараз починаємо сам процес внедрення в коучинг цих компетенцій.
Тому мені дуже важливо, щоб ви не просто записували, молча кивали, а якщо я вас спрошую, включайте мікрофон і присутнійте, подавайте о себе, давайте о себе знати, задавайте вопросы.
На вопрос у нас, конечно, буде определене отдельное время для того, щоб ми не збивалися зі слайдів, зі самой теми.
Присутствуете, активничайте. Учась делать это, сейчас вы это будете... О, боже, наконец, меня видно лучше, а то я что-то... Да, замечательно.
Учась, уже научаясь здесь активно присутствовать, активно слушать, мы уже в работе с клиентами ведем себя совершенно иначе, понимаете? Уже.
Почему? Ну, об этом буду рассказывать дальше. Значит, первый перерыв, перейдем, у нас он будет через один час.
Сейчас мы начинаем уже активно переходить к слайдам. Вот.
И так, я думаю, что все уже присоединились. Приступаем. Активное слухання як професійна навичка коуча.
Що ж, ми сьогодні будемо з вами розбирати.
Ми знаходимо, заходимо в одне з найважливіших місць в коучингу – це слухання, і це шоста компетенція.
Що ми будемо досліджувати сьогодні?
Активне слухання як стан присутності.
Буквально 2 минути, я соберусь, тому що у мене 8 утра, встала я практично в 5.30.
Для того, щоб підготовитися к зустрічі.
Так, активне слухання як стан присутності.
Слухання без інтерпретації і реакції.
Ми будемо досліджувати роботу з невербалікою, інтонація, пауза, мимика, дихання, жести.
Сьогодні прям очень багато будемо об цьому говорити.
Будемо досліджувати тілесну присутність і тіло як інструмент слухання.
А зараз, пока я перейду к тому, що тут у нас написано і як це все об'язняється,
будь ласка скажіть, є ли у вас розуміння?
Оно у вас є, це однозначно, тому що ви вже спеціаліст,
і багато з вас коучи, багато з вас практикують.
А ще більше можете мені розказати, о чому ми будемо сьогодні говорити?
Як це для вас? Що це таке для вас слушати?
Що це таке для вас слухать без інтерпретации і реакції?
Понимайте руки, щоб ми не перебували.
Вікторія, да, або хто?
Да, да, да. Включенец процес, давання понимання чоловіку,
наскільки важливо то, о чому він говорить.
Це значимость, важність, що ви повністюєте в ньому.
Внимателі. Людям не хватає такої коммуникації,
як іменно тоді, коли їх слухають.
Отлично, дякую багато.
Так, а як ви пам'ятаєте?
Добре, Юля, Юля, ваш варіант.
Так, мені насправді це дуже цікаво,
тому що дуже часто клієнт приходить в роботу
і він говорить одне, а насправді в нього може бути зовсім інше.
Коли ми будемо не просто слухати його слова,
а активно знати, як інтерпретувати паузи,
як його жести можемо розуміти,
то ми зможемо вести клієнта туди, де йому дійсно важливо.
Не просто те, що він говорить,
бо дуже часто ми можемо говорити одне, а відчувати зовсім інше.
Так, звісно.
Так, є ще? Наталя може.
Я бачу, сьогодні нас дуже мало, 23 чоловіка.
А де остальні? Я не можу зрозумітися.
Ще чоловік десять, як минимум, не присоединилась.
Так, ждем еще.
І Наталья Нотса, може, ви скажете.
Еще, не стесняйтесь.
Як ви розумієте слухання?
Смотрите, якщо ви не будете говорити, не буде коммуникації...
Давайте я скажу.
Секундочку.
Якщо ви не будете говорити, не буде коммуникації,
це буде просто безполезна начитка слов без якого-либо веса.
І просто буде презентация, яка у вас просто лежит.
Но на самом деле, смотрите, вот я уже с вами коммуницирую, хочу слышать от вас, как вы меня слышите, как вы ощущаете мое присутствие.
Вот это уже есть работа, когда мы заходим с клиентом, и мы уже начинаем присутствовать.
Мы не всегда можем что-то говорить, но мы присутствуем, понимаете?
Вот это вот внедряем. Дальше еще больше подробностей будем рассуждать, как это работает.
Да, Юрий, говорите.
Активне слушання – це пространство, в якому чоловік видить, що внимание направлено к нему, і він може розкритися по-настоящому, тому що це те, чого сильно не хватає в житті, дуже багато діалогів,
вони поверхностні, і чоловік вроде хоче щось сказати, а його перебили, перебили, перебилися на тим на другу, і він не чувствує, що це важливо.
А коли він видит, що його слушають, дають пространство для пауз, для того, щоб він подумав, для рефлексії, він думає, що це важливо, я кажу.
Це розкрыває людину, його личність і дає пространство для інсайдів і чого-то ще.
Так, отлично, так, тому що є те моменти, коли ми дійсно знаєте, що ми робимо?
Це вже наш другий слайд, Наталя, секундочку, да, я вже розумію, ми починаємо розмовляти, розмовляємося чуть-чуть, є що сказати, супер.
Є те моменты, коли ми можемо слушати, ну ми сидимо такі і слушаємо, ну ми слушаємо, ну окей, слушаємо, що далі? Чоловік говорить, говорить, говорить, говорить, ми слушаємо, ми не в телефоне, да, ми н
игде, ми не втыкаємо в якусь точку, ми просто смотримо.
Але, знаєте, цей контакт, який відсувається, який його відсуває, клієнт його відсуває, він його відсуває, він відбуває, що вам неінтересно, що вам взагалі все одно, що ви там говорите.
Тому це присутствие ми цим і беремо. Ми, коучи, психотерапевти, психологи, ми беремо цим присутствие в першу чергу для того, щоб людина ощутила всім своєм нутром, що є те, хто дійсно його слухає.
Наталья, я помню, я ж вас спрашиваю.
Тут ще такий момент, коли я, наприклад, во взаємодействію с клієнтом, я понимаю, що я його слушаю не тільки ушами, я його слушаю і телом.
Ну вот полностью прям, потому что даже иногда откликається,
когда у него где-то что-то начинает давить, і йдет ощущение в телеске.
В плане того, что наскільки глубокий контакт, когда глаза, уши, тело,
і ти повністю включен в клиента, в человека, с кем би ти не взаємодействував.
І, соответственно, тоді йдет це відчування, де, що спросити.
Даже нескільки на рівні знання, наскільки на рівні очищення, знання.
І це дає намного більш клубоку картину взаємодії і того, що хоче бачить клієнт.
Клас, отлично. А ви сказали «чувствую телом».
Що значить «чувствую телом»? Де ви в телі чувствуєте людина?
Як ви це для себе определяєте?
Щас я попробую розуміти, тому що вона вже так як-то виходить на автоматизмі.
Чувствую телом.
Коли человек починає описувати, до того, як він починає описувати,
мене давить в груди, і у мене в цей момент тоже починає давить.
Даже до того, як він це озвучився, і від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від
від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від
від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від від
Дуже до того, як він це озвучився, і йде тут відчування, що тяжесть в плечах, тяжесть в груди, ну, таке відчування тіла.
Ви розумієте, що срабатує ваше емпатія, ваша частичка емпатії, коли ви відчуваєте людина полностью в центрі сонечного сплетення.
Окей, хорошо, спасибо большое. Татьяна Артемова, що ви хотіла сказати? Артемова.
Артемова, так. Я хотіла ще додати до того, що колеги сказали, що для мене це про те, щоб помічати динаміку змін продовж сесії.
От, наприклад, темп, з яким клієнт казав на початку і як він змінився в кінці.
Або, наприклад, як змінюється енергія, як тіло відгукується на якісь фрази чи запитання, наприклад, і повертати це клієнту.
Як змінюється на початку, як змінюється в кінці. Тобто ви фіксуєте на початку, яким чином і де клієнт відчуває свій стан наразі. Я правильно розумію?
Так, щоб повернути цю динаміку, щоб клієнт сам помітив.
І в кінці, ви не забуваєте також фіксувати цей стан?
Так.
Який інструмент ви використовуєте для цього?
Я просто повертаю у пряму комунікацію.
Угу, клас.
І про що це для тебе також можу запитати?
Тобто я помітила, що от така була динаміка, як для тебе.
Клас, клас, супер.
І тут ми класно використовуємо цей простий інструмент, який я називаю шкала від 1 до 10. Дети. Ми про це говорили. Це дуже класно, дуже просто. Дети зараз від 1 до 10.
На початку, де ти себе відчуваєш, де в своєму цілі ти відчуваєш цю проблему, цей запит, про який ти говориш, і де ти відчуваєш наприкінці.
Клас, супер, супер. Ось так ми починаємо трошечки розмовляти.
Дякую велике. Повертаємося до нашої презентації.
Так, я вже так зайшла в цю дію, що вже забула, де моя презентація, скажіть будь ласка.
Ось моя презентація, ви її бачите?
Бачите, так? Скажіть голос.
Да, все одно.
Клас, супер. Поехали далі.
Так, здрасте, на мене не листається. Ладно, хорошо, ми зробимо по-другому.
Зділаємо от так. Отлично. І так, що таке активне слухання? От ми зараз з вами дослідили, що таке активне слухання.
І це не про уважне кивання. Це зовсім не про уважне кивання. Це стан тотальної присутності, у якому ти відкритий до того, що буде. Тобто це про те, що ми зараз з вами роз'ясняли. Ми не слухаємо, щоб
зреагувати.
І це дуже важливо, що я хочу зараз объяснить. Ми дійсно не слухаємо для того, щоб среагувати, щоб лише б було, тому що ситуація, коли ми реагуємо просто тому, що треба, так не роботи. Нічого не вийде
, коли ми робимо просто тому, що треба, тому що треба. Тому що це, ну, прийшовте, ми маємо кивнути. Нет, так не роботи.
Я дуже часто вижу розбори ко мене, коли на супервізію я состою також, являюсь членом Европейско-Украинської ассоційно-когнітивно-повіденческих психотерапевтів, і дуже часто вижу на супервізіях, коли
ми приносимо свої відео, приносимо розбори, я вижу, наскільки клієнт розмовірє, а це про селф-дискавери і про момент присуття.
Спеціаліст не включен.
І це видно, що не включен, чоловік не включен.
Коли чоловік не включен, я прекрасно вижу вас.
Я вижу, хто включен в процес, я вижу, хто не включен в процес.
Я не можу сказати, хто не включен, хто включен, хто включен.
Я дуже добре вижу, хто включен в процес.
Кто роботає, кому це важливо, кому це не важливо, хто як реагує.
Именно це і є наша тема. Це глибінний рівень розуміння по вербаліки, по тому, як... по невербаліки, по тому, як чоловік реагує, як він двигається, куди він дивиться, куди він дивиться, де його руки.
І знаєте, порой у нас у всіх є защітні маски, реакції на ліце, які дуже рідко ми можемо считати, знаєте, як за правду.
І порой ти дивишся на чоловік і думаєш, ну він дурочка, а він дурачок, а цей дурачок чи ця дурочка вже ученій в третій степені.
Такой смотрит тоже на себя, но нічого не говорит.
Почему? Потому что он видит и считывает твою вербалику
и понимает, о чём ты, о чём ты здесь сейчас, да?
И там вот у нас включается наше эго, наше супер-эго.
Мы понимаем на глубинном уровне, где мы кого и как слышим, что происходит.
Понимаете, вот о чём я.
И здесь именно вот в сегодняшнем дне мы говорим про это.
Поэтому, когда мы сейчас зайдём в практику или в рефлекси,
Я буду говорить, быстро стараться в таймінг зайти,
хотя для мене це сложно, ви знаєте.
Але при цьому будемо пытатися максимально включатися в цей процес
в слушання на глибинному рівні.
Ми вже говорили, глибинна слухання ціна я тебе розумію,
а я з тобою в цьому.
Дайте, будь ласка, мені два приклади,
як ми з вами можемо показати, що це значить, я з тобою в цьому.
Два приклади. Коли ми не говоримо бла-бла-бла-бла-бла, без конца.
А вот как вы можете показати человеку в сесії, своєму клиенту,
що я з тобою в цьому процесі? Скажіть, будь ласка, двома якими-то словами,
як ви показуєте це? У нас, середі нас, є такожі специалисти. Говоріть, будь ласка об цьому.
Ну я написала как вопрос, зеркалить клиента.
Що ви понимаєте, що значить зеркалить?
Ну зеркалить, ну вот зеркало, вот зеркалить.
Ну я думаю, що це, ти даже коли ти молчиш, да, то есть ти присутствуєш, да,
то есть може бути соответствуюча поза така ж, як у клиента.
Якщо він розслаблен, то і коуч не сидить скований там, і наклонений, да,
то есть якщо наоборот клиент більш напрямок, то, наверное,
Нужно самому почувствовать своє состояние, да, там, і помочь розслабиться.
Ну, я там, например, думаю, можуть дыхательні якісь таки практики.
Ну, вот дзеркалити – це подражати мимики, там, движениям, там, ну, якщо вже розговор, то тональності, да, для какой-то коммуникації, для того, щоб чоловік почувствував доверительне відношення.
Тональність я отсюда заберу, тембр голоса, от, що це значить.
Понімаєте, слова, які ми тут вивчаємо, це слова, окей, вони класні, вони модні, вони супер-супер-супер чудові.
Але ми повинні розуміти, що є під грунтям, під тими словами.
Тобто, ось той тембр голосу, якщо клієнт говорить тихо, спокійно, то коуч ніяк не відповідає, ти знаєш, я тебе зараз розумів, тра-та-та-та-та-та-та.
Коуч так не відповідає, так?
Ось, це є, коли ми дзеркалимо.
І ми дзеркалимо, ми відповідаємо тим самим тембром.
Чекаю, хто ще мені підскаже.
Давайте два слова.
Я дуже намагаюся, дуже намагаюся говорити на українській мові, бо я практикую і записую себе, тому стараюся, я тут трошечки буду запинатися, але…
Є такий погляд, я би називав його роздягаючий, бо ти дивишся на клієнта, і він розуміє, що ти його просто…
Юрій, ми не роздягаємо клієнтів, Юрій, ми не роздягаємо клієнтів, я знаю цей погляд, дівчата теж його знають.
Ви не роздягаєтеся, я говорю про себе.
Якщо ви її почнете роздягати, повірте.
Я перевіряв.
Процес буде працювати інакше.
А, так ви перевіряв.
Ви ще, о май гад, добре.
Хорошо працює.
Можете спробувати, рекомендую.
І як присоединення, як коммуникація після цього? Наскільки глупо клієн закриватися?
Очень добре, дуже искренне, до глибини душі.
Так, всі нові студенти, ми зараз говоримо.
Мені просто інтересно, як працює цей інструмент у мужчин.
Ось сьогодні було в нас обоих були сльози на глазах, от так було, от тільки що сесії закінчили, у нас прямо сльози на глазах пішли обоих.
Ти іскренні смотриш просто в глаза, що чоловік розумієш, що ти в його душу заглядуєш.
Мені хочеться пошуткувати, як код із Шрека ви заглядували.
Забираємо. Забираємо. Значить що? Тембр голоса? Так. Забираємо його. Тембр.
Тональність, з якою говорить до нас клієнт. Друге, що ми забираємо? Ми забираємо погляд. Але погляд дійсно не роздягаючий, погляд такий, щирий погляд, ще зараз трошки хочу сказати про погляд.
Як ви вважаєте? Коли до тебе спеціаліст дивиться ось так і не відводить погляд, що це є для вас? Скажіть мені.
За мною слідять, кажеться.
А якщо в сесії клієнт каже, чому ви на мене не дивитесь постійно? Чому ви відводите свій погляд?
Я таким чином вважаю, що вам це дуже не цікаво, те, що я вам говорю.
Що ви будете робити в такому випадку, скажіть?
Я можу сказати, ну, дати малишку сидіть. Давай нормально поговоримо.
На жаль, так не можна.
Але якщо ви вже другий рік поспіль, то ви вже будете розуміти, чому так сьогодні він вдруг вирішив так сказати.
Але реально, що ви будете робити?
Друга сесія.
Випадок.
Мій випадок.
Я питаю все зі свого випадку, зі своїх кейсів, зі своєї практики.
Друга сесія.
Клієнтка каже ось такі речі.
Я скажу, що я робила.
Але після того, як ви дасте свої відповіді.
Я можу таки...
Давайте, так.
Як часто ти таке відчуваєш в житті?
І просто сказати, що це була моя провокація.
Я часто різними речами.
Що я провокував тебе.
Типу, я побачив, що це тебе може стригерити.
І мені було цікаво, що за цим справді щось стоїть.
Постерігав з гіпункою.
Юрій, цікава думка.
Поясню.
Зараз послухаю других і поясню, чому і чому, і що і як.
Це у вас зв'язок преривається чи у мене?
Скажіть, будь ласка.
У Юрія чи у мене?
Хто скаже?
У Юри.
Трошки у Юри, так?
Бо я в новій обстановці,
поэтому я не дуже розумію,
як працюю в Wi-Fi,
але ці два тижні працювало все добре.
Ще, будь ласка, ще приклади.
Пам'ятаємо, так, чому ви не смотрите на мене?
Чому вам що не інтересно, що я говорю?
Додайте, може додати те, що це якийсь психотип людини, додайте, додайте щось, тут працює все, тут працює все, додайте.
Ну, з тривожним якимось розстройством, з маніакальним якимось чумом.
А, ні, це якщо ми не дивимося, якщо дивимося пристрійно, то можна сказати, щоб не смущати.
Типа, може, я не дивлюся так пристально, щоб не смущатися, щоб ви могли розкритися.
А якщо контракт заключається на першій сесії, це була вторая, то там же проговариваються якісь такі моменти, да, то есть, наприклад, що коуч може ввести запись, і можна сказати, що коли я, ви думаєте
, що я відвлекаюсь, я записую то, що може помочь нам в дальнішем, да, то есть за вами.
Об этом ми говоримо, да, Оксана, абсолютно точно, потому що на першій сесії, вот вчера у мене пришла, зашла ко мене пара, а после того, як я розказую, для того, щоб не терять вот этот уровень слуш
ання і присутствие, я объясняю, смотрите, ви будете видеть, що я отвлекаюсь, я показываю, що вот моя ручка, вот мої листи, или мій блокнот, і я буду за вами писати, я записываю всегда історію, я не п
ечатаю на, мне удобно писати, я люблю це,
я люблю, в общем, записувати за клиентом.
Да, ви правы, хорошо.
Але що, в случае, є ще варіанты?
Скажіть, є ще варіанты, коли людина без конца,
не людина, а сам клієнт, говорить,
чому ви на мене не смотрите,
чому ви відводите взгляд?
Ви часто відводите взгляд,
чому ви це робите?
Вам не інтересна моя історія?
Якщо мені с этим ок, і прям, ну, мені так хочеться,
я скажу, слушай, давай так,
Я вот це, вот это, вот это, вот это услышав.
Ну, я могу пойти прямо в конфлікт і разграть мини-сценку конфлікта.
І посмотреть тоже, как человек себя ведет.
І туди тоже много смыслов витащить.
Клас. Супер. Спасибо, Юра.
Значить, поясню. Насправді, це не пружу, Юля, Юля Печенка.
Якщо тобі це важливо, може мати постійний здоровий контакт,
але зустрі, то такий контакт може давати ефект напруження.
Насправді, навіть коли я не дивлюсь вам в очі, я уважно вас слухаю.
Так, дуже класно пояснили. Я дійсно так пояснила, що дійсно, навіть коли я не дивлюсь в очі, я дуже уважно вас слухаю, але тут важливо відзначити, що клієнт має нарцистичний тип розгляду.
Ось, це важливо відзначити.
Да, с відсутнім він може бути, і тому йому важна вовлечувальність, це полна.
Абсолютно, абсолютно, да, абсолютно, дуже важна, понимаєте? Діло в тому, що ми вернемся к нашій презентції і продовжимо далі наш розговор.
Діло в тому, що ми, коли говоримо о своєму слушанні...
А видно мою презентацию, нет?
Так, так видно.
Отлично, супер.
Супер.
Дело в тому, що коли ми слушаємо...
Та що ж таке, я сьогодні, як Маша Растеряша з утра, їй Богу, то я екран не можу настроити, то я вас закрываю.
Галерея. Вернусь сейчас, секундочку, секундочку, секундочку.
Дівчатки, підтримайте мене, будь ласка. Йолечка, підтримайте мене, будь ласка, не можу врубити,
чому я бачу студентів, студенти бачать мою презентацію, а я свою презентацію не бачу.
Ви в зумі зараз знаходитеся, коли ви розмовляєте зі студентами, її ставити, тобто не демонструвати екран.
Так, все, все, я вам гарно.
Спасибо большое, все, возвращаемся.
Значить, о чому я хотела сказати? Ловлю мисль дальше.
Очень важно понимати, розуміти всі аспекти.
Коли ми заходимо з клієнтом в працю, особисто що роблю я?
В моїй практиці я всегда, во-первых, заключаю контракт, контракт я вам збросила,
«Ви получили мой контракт? Получили ли ви в Телеграме мой контракт? На второму модулю? Отлично! И вопросы так же я вам сбрасила. Замечательно! Закрытые, открытые вопросы. В первую очередь, когда я
устанавливаю контракт, я так же для лучшего и большего понимания предлагаю тестирование.
Тестировання не є якимось, звичайно, окончательним вариантом і результатом якого-то діагноза,
або якого-то предположення діагноза, але при цьому я краще розуміюю, з яким чоловіком я працюю.
І це дає мені можливість більше вникнути в клієнта, понимати, як його слухати, на якому рівні.
Я всегда предлагаю тестировання. В першу чергу, це определення урвання тревожного урвання своєго, це шкала Аарона Бека. Обязательно розуміти, де на якому урвання він знаходиться.
Якщо я слышу, що чоловік обеспокоє, допустим, соцюм,
чи обеспокоє окруження люди,
я обязательно скидываю тестироване на посттравматическое стресове расстройство
і предлагаю пройти тест Ненси МакВильям на понимание психотипа личности.
Там більше ста вопросів в оригинале.
Т.е. я предлагаю, я не навязываю, предлагаю пройти тест Ненси МакВильям.
Конечно же, клієнт говорить «да», потому что це интересно.
Для нього у мене ще не було нікого, хто б отказався знати себе краще, а я, коли получаю результаты после першої ознаковительной сесії, понимаю, як краще на нього реагувати.
І ось тут якраз ми говоримо, ми наслухаємо ще б зреагувати, ми слухаємо ще б клієн почув себе.
Коли ми краще, коли ми краще розуміємо, як слухати, як слухати клієнта, тому що ми вже маємо менше більше, чим то, о чому він себе говорить на першій сесії.
Тоді наш рівень слушання включається гораздо краще.
На кого, Юрий? На тест Нэнси Маквиллем?
Ага, вот эти три теста, що ви назвали?
А взагалі не проблема. Взагалі не проблема. Взагалі я сброшу в групу і декілька вам перекинуть.
Я можу вам збросити все тестированные для того, щоб ви розуміли, що...
Перша сесія, я всегда поняла.
Почему?
Потому что, во-первых, вы лучше и быстрее, эффективнее берете клиента.
Вы его просто захватываете со всех сторон.
Потому что что?
То, что вы понимаете, есть у него сейчас депрессия, нет депрессии.
То есть не депрессия, а на какому уровні она?
Слабая, ярко выраженная.
Где он сам может справиться?
Какой психотип личности?
Там шизотипический, нарциссический, мазохистический, обсессивно-компульсивный, истерический.
Ви понимаєте, істерички, вони ж по-другому реагують, шизоїды, вони по-другому, маниакальні по-другому, нарцисси по-другому, і ви вистраєте цей контакт з ними вже з першої сесії, і ви, що ви діляєте?
Конечно, ви краще продаєте, ви продаєте, вони такі, бахи, у вас пакетами 10-20 сесій ушло, тому що що, тому що клієнт, він не просто вас услышав, він вас почувствував, він говорить, да, ви мій спеці
аліст, вот оно, це слухання.
Завтра будемо говорити більше о присутстві, а сьогодні продолжаєм далі. Сброшу. Обязательно, дівчі, напомніте мені, будь ласка, Юлечка, щоб я сбросила, як я вдруг забуду. Єдем далі. Ідемо к рефлексії
. Рефлексія, рефлексія, не важна. І так, і так, правильно? Лучше її научно, конечно, рефлексія.
Де ви чуєте себе, перше питання, як ви відчуваєте, що вас справді слухають?
Зараз повернемося до себе і запишіть, будь ласечка, відповіді на ці два питання.
Я б отмідала одне важливіше з них, як ви відчуваєте, що вас справді слухають.
Де ви чуєте себе і як ви відчуваєте?
Дві хвилиночки.
Можете записати, можете просто подумати про це.
Чи є хтось, хто може поділитися зі мною?
Хто може поділитися зі мною своїм станом і своїм відчуттям?
Коли задають уточнюючі питання, йдуть в глибину.
Клас.
Так.
Тобто, Юрій, ви там чуєте себе, так?
Коли вам задають уточнюючі питання.
Ні, ви сказали, як ви відчуваєте, що вас справді слухають.
Друге питання важливіше. Я на нього написав.
Я собачую в тишині зазвичай на прогулянці.
Анна, дякую, дякую Юрий, дякую.
Тоже, коли задають уточняючі випроси, коли кивають.
Якщо це встреча, оффлайн, то гляда, мимика, тишина, пауза.
Так я відчуваю, як мене слушаю.
Класс! А гляда які, такі? Чи ні?
Ні, звісно, знаєте, з інтересом, такі, якби вони слухаються,
якби вони хочуть слухати ще щось.
Так, ви слухаєте, так, ви відчуєте. Дякую.
Дякую велике. Валерія, так, Валерія Кучма.
Я поділюсь, як я відчуваю.
Для мене, я знаю свій тип особистості,
для мене важливо, щоб зі мною підтримували зоровий контакт,
але не отак, як ми говоримо, але при цьому та, щоб не вітали десь там в хмаринках.
Мені важливо, щоб користувалися моїми метафорами, тому що я дуже метафорично мислю,
і іноді могли запропонувати якісь свої на якусь тему чи напрямок,
щось, можливо, це також дасть, а також, коли відмічають мої стани,
зміни в енергетиці, зміни в емоціях, тоді я розумію, що людина зі мною,
і вона чує не тільки те, що я через рот кажу, а й невербальною складовою.
Тобто не тільки як людина, міміка, жести, а й як вона реагує на мої.
Клас, супер. Метафора мені дуже подобається, тому що я про себе скажу.
Я дуже поважаю метафору, і коли мені її повертають мою метафору, розкриваючи її,
і не дуже відношуся до того, якщо я говорю метафорою, наприклад, чайник скіпів, а мені кажуть, вулкан зірвався.
Ні, тут скоріше про продовження, ну, типу, коли воно одне за одним чіпляється, так.
Так, так, так, так, бо коли, і тут зараз беріть на заміточку собі, бо коли ви чуєте, що коли клієнт сказав чайник скіпів, то в нього дійсно чайник скіпів, не вулкан, не дом згорів, дім, нічого, а це
про чайник.
І він каже, як ти себе там відчуваєш, коли той чайник там свистить, і коли він починає закіпати, як ти себе тоді почуваєш, а коли він закінчив, а що треба зробити, щоб він закінчив вскіпати?
А що навколо стається, коли цей чайник? Розумієте, все навколо цього чайника. І ми вкидуємо, накидуємо, накидуємо цих уточнюючих питань і тим самим ми показуємо, наскільки ми класно і чуйно відносимо
ся до свого клієнта.
Анастасія Виноградова. Так, бачу вашу руку.
Добрый вечер.
Как я ощущаю, що мене слухають?
Ну, первое, це коли не відвікаються на совершенно посторонніе вещи.
Ну, то есть перебиваю там, ой, смотри, какая погода, али природа.
Второе, коли я починаю говорить тише, я вижу, що человек включається телом
і починає ко мене двигатися, щоб услышати.
то есть это для меня большой ну я сразу вижу этот показатель и третье когда продолжает мой
разговор моими словами то есть ты ну например за задав мне вопрос да я начну отвечать и меня
подхватывает моими же словами дальше развиваю ну как чайник только слова только именно диалог
Не петафора, а прямой разговор.
Настя, уточняючий вопрос, можна?
Да.
Скажите, пожалуйста, когда я говорю тише, человек ко мне наклоняється.
Это, ещё раз, объясните, в каком контексте для вас?
Ну, например, когда вы как кто?
Ну, как клиент, например, как клиент.
Так, так, хорошо. Ну да, мы разбираем сейчас ситуацию.
як я відчуваю, що вас насправді слухаєтесь, коли ви, чи правильно я зрозуміла, коли ви говорите тихіше, і к вам...
Я вважаю, що чоловік спочиняється, він як би прислушатися хоче.
Тобто він настільки в розмові, це може бути не спеціально.
Я емоційний чоловік, я говорю громко-громко-громко,
а потім я задумалася в мисі, починаю її тихо,
і я смотрю, що чоловік, він як би хоче то слухати, він прям підтягивається.
Для мене це зразу считається як чоловік весь во вниманні.
Отлично. Невербальна і невербальна. Клас, спасибо большое. Олена Сідик.
Ну, мені важливо, щоб був, по-перше, контакт, тому що в мене були такі ситуації, наприклад, з директором,
ми там сидимо, обсуждаємо, на мій погляд, якусь там важливу річ, а він при цьому сидить в телефоні.
І мені не ок. Я йому кажу, якщо ти зараз зайняти, я зайду пізніше.
Ні-ні, я тебе слухаю.
Хвилиночку, хвилиночку, дивіться, хвилиночку, що я хочу сказати.
Ви кажете, якщо ти зараз зайнятий, розумієте, я буду виправляти, є такі, я дозволю собі з вашого дозволу трошечки виправити, є такі речі, я скроллю ленту, я дійсно не зайнята.
Але якщо та людина, з ким я спілкуюся, хоче моєї уваги, я кажу, ти мене спитаєш, забери, будь ласка, телефон.
Мені через «я» повідомлення дуже незручно, що ти зараз пялишся в телефон, блін!
Зрозуміть, коли ми говоримо зайняте, людина не зайнята, вона не зайнята, вона там робить щось собі в телефоні.
Уточнуйте. Ти мене зараз, якщо слухаєш, було б дуже класно, все залежить від відносин з цією людиною, з якою ви знаходитесь.
Все залежить від цих відносин. Мене дратує, що ти сидиш в телефоні, я пішла, все.
Так, воно реально, що людина тебе не чує, що вона не з тобою зараз, а десь там.
Ще коли мені дають сказати до кінця і не передаваючи, це теж для мене важливо для того, щоб я розкрила, що мене чують і слухають.
і коли іспользують діалоги ті слова, котрими я кажу.
Так, клас.
Ну, тут в лекціях я перебиваю.
Часто я перебиваю?
Ні, ну ви перебиваєте яку.
Ні, ну ви перебуваєте яку.
Смотите я вас так само.
Це трошки інакше виглядає,
ніж коли просто ти там щось говориш-говориш,
а інша людина почала там вже щось своє,
Причому на таких високих децибелах, наприклад, і ти просто навіть розумієш, що це було.
Вісно, розуміє. Анна, ви хотіли доповнити, чи у вас рука просто поднята?
Нет, я хотіла додати, коли людина в телефоні, я просто прекращаю говорити.
Тобто я даю йому можливість вовлечься в то, що він хоче.
І тоді хоп, а що ти замовчала? Ну, ти же рідом не зі мною.
і все, вони включаються, да-да-да, що ти там сказала, що ти повторила.
Тишина дуже добре реагує на тишу.
Там був повний фон, такий бла-бла-бла, щось ти там розказує.
А клас, все супер, там Моцарт на фоні, тут Моцарт затих.
О, що сталося? Так, вісно, Настя Вінограда ви хотіли додати?
у меня такой вопрос я по себе когда я очень сосредоточена и хочу донести хорошо правильно
мысль свою то есть где-то в глубину ухожу наверно в этот момент я могу отвлекаться я могу что-то
какой-то там если у меня есть ручка зарисовывать или крутить ну то есть это тоже может расцениться
человеком что я его невнимательно слушаю но меня это как отвлекающий момент это из детства то есть
Я уроки робила идеально, коли у мене на фоне що-то разговаривало,
що-то там, телевізор, музика, ну, обязательно.
І тоді я більш сконцентрирована.
Тобто я можу дуже сконцентрирована в розмові дуже серйозно
і прям сидіти, рисувати на полях.
Ну, це клас.
Це якщо у мене зараз прийшло в голову синдром дефіцита внимання,
то це взагалі не...
Проти втраті втраті.
Да, Вікторія, ми тож реагували.
Да, є люди, я, допустим, я можу сидеть в телефоні,
Точно так же я слушаю музику
или що-то делаю, я лучше запоминаю.
І це не значить, що я не вовлечена.
Просто у мене синдром дефіц...
Я не можу даже фільм смотреть, просто смотреть.
Мені нужно що-то робити, інакше я взагалі не вовлекусь.
Тобто це точно так же, як ми будемо психотипу человека,
с расстройством він или нет.
Але якщо він обладає С2Г, то не знає, що він не слушає.
А касательно роботи...
А якщо там ієрархія существує?
Якщо це ти подчиненна, а це твій руководитель?
Ти ж не скажеш, мене бесить, що ти сидиш в телефоне.
Тобто, як в такому випадку действувати?
Щас відвечу спочатку на випадку Насти і відвечу на випадку Ваш.
Насть, дивіться, є ситуація, я розумію прекрасно,
коли ми щось зарисовуємо, коли ми щось робимо.
Ви можете в роботі з клієнтом...
Я б чудово, я тут не одна така, Алина Великина.
Ви можете безусловно с клиентом в сопровождении, знаєте, мягко ему об этом сказати.
Що я отвлеку, отвлекаюсь, на що? На що ви отвлекаєтесь?
Ви, смотрите, це дуже тонка грань, це дуже тонкий вопрос, це дійсно тонкий вопрос.
У вас є протоколи, ви, безусловно, ми требуємо від клієнта, да, тож якісь правил.
І ми всі прекрасно розуміємо, що ці правила потрібно соблюдувати.
Але випадок ума і соображительності і цей гибкості ніхто не відменяв.
Я завжди кажу, що все можна, але головне – це зробити таким образом,
щоб і вам було комфортно, і вашому клієнту було комфортно.
Якщо вам так удобно слухати і слухати, безусловно, вот так вот топором говорити,
Типа, ви знаєте, ви там будете разговаривать, ви будете объяснять свій запрос, а я тут буду эту мандалу, мандала, мандала, как я не знаю, как она правильно називається, розрисовування.
А?
Ну, не важно, да.
Да, вот, як-то її там рисувати і розрисовувати, понимаєте?
То есть, ви, коли заходите в роботу з клиентом, во всяком случае, нічого же не случиться.
якщо ви один час його послушаєте,
послушайте так, як є,
і далі вже будете для себе корректирувати,
що ви зможете добавляти в процесі,
що вам так дійсно буде комфортній
з ним далі працювати.
Ну, при знакомстві, при неглубокій роботі
це дуже навіть легко зараз.
Ну, конечно, вже опыти.
І дуже легко сосредоточитися і не займатися ним.
Коли дуже глубокий процес від роботи,
то я можу прям,
прям це автоматично працює.
Ну, ви знаєте, ніколи в житті ні разу мені ніхто не сказав,
ти мене не слухаєш.
Тому що я як-то максимально звернула на нього.
Человек відчувається, що я наоборот,
на стільки прогрузилась з ним в його ситуацію, в його розговор.
Просто є такий момент, да.
Я можу в цей момент, я потім раз, все, ми розмовляємо далі,
і я смотрю, що у мене вже там картина Репина,
і в принципі можна взяти фишки в конці клієнту дарити.
Ви подняли дуже таку інтересну тему.
Да, Алина, вижу, Оксанка, вижу.
Ви подняли очень интересную тему.
Почему? Потому что лет 5 назад, ну не 5, может быть, 4,
пока я не начала изучать психіатрию,
и пока я не начала глубоко уходить в диагнозы,
я бы, наверное, реагировала как-то более топорно.
Из разряда того, что, типа, ну, это же всего лишь один час,
но вы же можете себя контролировать,
вы же можете как-то повести себя иначе,
вы же можете выбрать другой какой-то...
Це тож можливо, але, знаєте, це як раз ситуація, виїзд із країни, поступлення в другий університет,
изучення, глибше, психіатрию, изучення діагнозів, і робота з людьми, які особенні, несовершенні, особенні,
по-разному їх можна звати, научила мене смотреть на речі зовсім інакше, абсолютно інакше, не так, як смотрять на речі там, де я жила,
т.е. в моїй родній Україні, в моїй родній Одесі.
Почему?
Тому що, дійсно,
ну, вот, посмотри, давайте возьмем
историю, ми далеко ходити не будем,
научно доказанні факты, Эйнштейн,
він був з діагнозом, на секундочку,
щас вам скажу, із СДВГ,
це була не дискалькулія,
а була дислексія.
Якщо мені пам'ять не зміняє,
можете мені проверити, що-то таке.
Вот, дискалькулія – це, значить,
проблем со счетом, дислексія –
Проблема з писанином і з письмом, і з чтением.
Значить, візьмем Моцарта, він теж був болен.
Візьмем Ван Гога, він теж був болен.
Ну, извините, але ці люди, вони ж мирового масштаба, ці люди, вони мають сумасшедші...
Це ж, коли ми знали, коли вони були боліни?
Коли ми знали?
Тільки після того, коли ми увидели їх прекрасне творчество.
І якщо хтось із нас інтересувався психикою цих людей, чи що с ним відбувається, тоді ми об цьому знали. А багато ж не знають, правильно? І ось, будь ласка, це якраз система гибкості, де якщо дійсно
вам допомагає, і дійсно вам це дає можливість глибше розуміти человека, ну, будь ласка.
Візьмем, я не беру сейчас примеры, я беру человека, допустим, из моментов,
когда обладають там высокой уровню чувствительности, а на самом деле они слепые,
на самом деле они там еще как-то, то есть другими какими-то болезнями, да.
Вот. Алина Велихина, дополніте.
Ну, я можу поділитися своїм лайфхаком, що я роблю, власне, на консультаціях.
Я або одягаю кілечки, які, ну, я, в принципі, їх не ношу, але саме на сесію я одягаю.
І я просто в процесі можу їх укрутити, їх можна кілька одягнути, тобто можна їх одягнути різні, вони ж є ребристі, такі шоколіці.
Тобто, от тут вже можна включити, якщо немає, там, я забула ще щось, ручка.
Тобто я просто в руці кручу ручку.
Да, да, саме так.
І на той період консультації, яку я проводжу,
мені вистачає цієї дії.
Зрозуміло, що коли вже закінчується, я максимально вмикаю активність
і тоді вже переключаюсь далі на наступному.
Так, клас. Ручка, бусики, чотики, колечки.
Це найкраще, що може дати вам можливість щось теребити в руках.
Да, ось вони, будь ласка.
мозга клієнта
обработати информацию,
то есть клієнт тебе її говорить,
а ти її і обрабатываєш, і видаєш,
і обмозговуєш, і ще варіанты сверху
даєш, і там не отвлекаєшся,
і, конечно же, нужно що-то,
і здесь даже можна,
ну, конечно, я думаю,
що було б неплохо ще, допустим,
с яким-то нейробіологом,
спеціалістом понять ще більше,
почему ми це робимо, тому що не завжди
це може бути проти синдрома дефіцита внимання,
Це буває ще просто від інших нюансів, як працює наш мозок,
і про чому нам потрібно це відвління, чи жистикуляція.
Але це дуже інтересні факти, які дійсно можна використовувати.
Дякую за лайфхак, Алина.
Беріть себе на заметку.
Не завжди можна опускати глаза.
Теребим щось, щоб нам допомагало.
Якщо для нас це ефективно, беремо все.
Все, що нам ефективно.
Оксаночка, ви хотіли додати?
Питання. У мене, скоріше, проблема не з тим, щоб вімкнути оце активне слухання.
У мене проблема з тим, щоб його вимкнути.
Тобто, навіть коли я працюю в студії, як лазеротерапевт,
я зараз не виходжу часто на роботу по тій причині,
що я занадто включаюся і проводжу дві процедури одночасно.
І це мене виснажує страшенно.
яким чином вийти з цього процесу, тобто сказати собі, що просто людина там не слухає,
там вона сказала, я своє роблю, ну я не знаю, я ще не навчалась, чи є такі...
Стоп, в голові стоп, є, це стопи, це коли ви робите себе стоп,
це коли ви відслеживаєте свої мисли, що ви слушаєте, що ви робите в моменті,
всігда ми задаємо самі себе вопрос, стоп, що я зараз делаю, стоп, що я зараз делаю,
Це перше. Якщо не срабатує автоматічна мисля, якщо ви не можете себе сподівати,
у вас є таймер, у вас є телефон, у вас процедура на час, у вас сработав таймер.
Кажді полчаса поставте. У вас процедура на час, кажді полчаса таймер ставте.
Кажді 20 минут. 20 минут будильничок там чуть-чуть.
Легка мелодія, яка никого не відвлечет, але ви її знаєте.
О чому она для вас?
О, простите, Анастасія?
Ой, да. Здравствуйте всем. Можно я чуть-чуть подключусь?
Просто тема інтересна, я добавлю лайфхак.
Я думала, що треба нас з'становити, поэтому, да.
Не-не-не, все нормально, все нормально, я просто вас тоже слушаю.
Просто це дуже про состояние коуч,
вот це состояние нуля, коли ти одновременно знаходишся
і в контакті з другим чоловіком, і в першу чергу в контакті з собою.
Вот якщо йде перекос більше в слияния,
коли ми йдем більше в контакт с чоловіком,
ми такі емпатичні, а ми коучи заразі все емпатичні,
У нас може бути це жилання
Немножко слиться з історією человека.
Але перша задача кожного коуча —
Це виробити сначала опору в себе
І вміти вважатися в себе.
І коли в нас достатньо сильна эта опора
І вистояние так називаємого нуля,
Коли ми просто чувствуємо своє тело,
Чувствуємо свої емоції в першу чергу,
То нам легче підтримувати дистанцію
Между своїми чувствами, пропускати
Пропускати другого чоловіка через себе
і при цьому не так сильно уставати от потока людей.
Вот цим хотела поделитися мислью.
Спасибо большое, отлично, конечно.
Да, я с вами согласна, контакт с собой, опора в себе без конца.
Это мы говорим об этом, когда у нас происходит слияние.
І об этом ми говорили про селф-дискавери, помните?
Це наше селф-дискавери, це наша основа, це наш фундамент.
І якщо ми йдемо без цього фундамента, ми починаємо це слияние.
Помніте о першому модулю, помніте о «Соук Дискавери». Обязательно.
Спасибо, Анастасія, що ви нам напомнили о цій важній темі.
Спасибо большое.
Оксаночка, ви хотіли додавати, і скоро будемо йти на перерів.
Я в двох словах про те, як я розумію, що мене слухають.
Тут є ще такі слова, по-український вигук или межнометие,
коли клієнт говорить там «вау», не клієнт, а собеседник.
Потому що я ж отвечаю на вопрос, там «вау», ну які-то такі, да, там, емоціональні,
«класс», ми самі ці слова говоримо.
Вот це для мене.
І ще такий момент, не тільки уточняючий вопросы, а коли продолжение, да, там,
а що-то вспомнил человек подобне, а вот какой-то не просто пример,
а привнёс мою какую-то тематику, да, привнёс что-то своё.
То вот это для меня тоже вовлечённость собеседника.
Класс, спасибо большое. Спасибо, Оксана.
Хорошо, друзья, класс, мне очень, скажите, как вам,
мне очень нравится наш с вами сегодня диалог.
Он такой классный, вы прям вникаете в это вот слушание,
Прямо заходите в цю позицію, що для мене це просто висший пилотаж.
Спасибо вам огромное, я слышу вас, вижу ваше сердечко, спасибо.
Так, у нас с вами, якщо я не ошибаюсь, полчасика до перерыва, і ми двигаємся далі.
Части слайдів, які у нас тут є, ми вже проговорили, да.
Ще таке, я їх далі зачитаю, у вас інформація все є.
Ще таке слухання в коучингу.
Це стан, у якому ти не просто чуєш слова, дійсно, а зустрічаєш живу присутність людини.
Через що? Ми відмітили з вами.
Через вербалику, через невербалику, через повернення, через відзеркалення, через повернення фраз, метафор, доповнення стану, метафор самого клієнта.
Через контакт в собі, через опору в собі, через наш фундамент внутрішній, який ми є.
І тоді ми слухаємо і зустрічаємо живу цю присутність людини.
Тут головне бути людиною в моменті, де вона шукає себе.
Бути з людиною в моменті, де вона шукає себе.
Так, дійсно, дуже поважаю метафори, я би всі слайди тільки метафорами видала. Тиша – це родючий ґрунт для проростання думки. Тиша, коли є тиша, коли ми даємо цю тишу.
Я вам тут в процесі не завжди можу дати цю тишу, бо у нас мало часу, зараз ви бачите, що у нас часу ще менше, потому що добавились ще у вас предметы, і я дуже надеюсь, що для вас це також полезно, но
ми стараємося взяти пользу із всього, вот здесь, вот, глубокого.
І це польза в першу очередь. Мої дорогі колеги, рождається здесь, в нашому с вами діалогі. Не тільки в цих слайдах, а именно в нашому с вами діалогі. То, як ви слишите, то, як ви чуствуете, то, як ви
ощущаєте.
Наш розум хоче додати думку, оцінку, пораду, але коуч очищає простір, залишаючи чисту присутність свою. І саме в цій порожнечі народжується щось нове.
Тут ми з вами поговоримо про небезпеку поверхневого слухання. Що це таке, коли клієнт каже, я втомилась, але не розумію чого, і тут коуч такий поверхнево, може вам потрібно більше відпочивати?
Клієнт, я втомилася, я не розумію цього, чого? Що в тобі відгукується, коли ти кажеш втомилася? Де є реакція неслухання, а де відкривається глибший пласт, сенси, страхи і очікування?
Так? Ми бачимо це і ми розуміємо, що коли нас слухають, коли не слухають. А тепер скажіть буквально одне слово, два слова голосом. Бувало у вас таке, коли, вспомніте случай, давайте так, вспомніте
случай, коли ви зрозуміли, що вас взагалі не слухає ніхто.
Ну не то, що ніхто, що вас не услышали. Був такий случай? Да, Виктория?
Я таке відкрила і думаю, так, що повністю не услышали. Я з усіми своїми синдромами.
Можете помнить момент, коли ви поняли, що реально вас не услышали?
Це не обов'язково в практиці, це психологічна.
Буває таке, що ти говориш,
вважаєшся к чоловікам,
як твое мінення,
а у нього розуміння нет, о чому ти спросив,
тому що цю частину він прослухав.
Тобто в телефоні завіст,
або ще гіди.
Тобто ти розказуєш історію, спрашуєш,
ну як тебе, чи що ти думаєш по цьому поводу,
і він завісає в цей момент,
і розумієш, що я відв'язався.
Зараз, жінчина,
вона менше адаптивній к цьому моменту,
вона може слушати,
а мужчина у нього не однозадачний, і якщо втикає в телефон, то автоматично, що в ній відбувається, він вже не слухає.
Ось таке в наблюденні.
Ага. Василь, бачу, часто в спілкуванні з колишніми. Ну, так. Звісно, чоловік рахується, звісно.
Ну, як може побачити, звісно, рахується, коли ти хочеш донести свою думку, і ти хочеш, щоб тебе почули, звісно, рахується кожна людина.
Так, Софійка, так, Софійка Роденко.
У мене були такі ситуації, але вони такі більше бізнесові, не теж у спартаках, таких, в очень жорстких переговорах, я би так сказала.
коли ти пітаєшся розуміти і вже приймаєш його,
тобто учитываєш його інтереси в тому числе,
але людина тебе не слухає, просто взагалі не слухає,
взагалі в якому-то відліті.
У мене таке відчування було раніше,
що як будь-то у людина просто немає понимання і знання,
що це взагалі означає, як це таке.
Як це бути тоді?
Буває, ти вже з усіх всіх сторон, але все одно як з стінку опираєшся і все.
Як бути в таких ситуаціях?
Це ви, коли вас не слухат,
або коли в розговорі з чоловіком?
В переговорах, я би так сказала.
В переговорах, да?
Настя, ви хотіли допомити на Софі, на відповідь?
Или ви просто свій вопрос хотіли сказати?
Я хотіла цю тему, да, теж підтримувати.
Ну, мені в переговорах, коли мені не слухат
і не розуміють, як ти говориш,
вроде ж понятним языком,
то іногда потрібно спуститися на рівень лінгвістики ниже,
первое, а второе перейти на більш прості метафори.
Секс, еда, секс, еда, що там ще,
і починаєш розказувати о пирожніх, бубликах.
Спасибо тебе, да, реально,
нас просто розмовляється на рівні чоловіка.
Спасибо, я ж розмовляється на рівні чоловіка.
Абсолютно, абсолютно, дуже класно.
Це коли, знаєте, момент, допустим,
якщо я розмовляюся з чоловіком,
у мене був клієнт, він механік,
Я йому говорила о двигателях. Я кажу, ти розумієш, якщо масла в двигателі немає, він ніколи не поїдеть, якщо у тебе клапана заржавелі, якщо у тебе ходовая не ходить. І все, і ми поїхали далі. Настя,
ми вас слушаємо.
Мені сьогодні так з вами цікаво, не можу відірватися.
Ну так, я теж хотіла доповнити і сказати в тему, що коучи ж виконують дуже часто,
ми виконуємо функцію education, дуже часто таке, бо людина не знає, якщо працює.
Ну, якщо у переговорах, це вважає те саме.
Особливо, якщо ти відчуваєш, що людина тебе не чує, тому що, може, йому десь не вистачає чогось,
якоїсь інформації або знань, то education функція завжди приходить на допомогу
у плані просто пояснити, і я тут погоджуюся, що більш простими метафорами може бути
також і більш зрозуміло. Але саме у сесіях завжди потрібно пояснювати.
Це працює.
Звісно, так, пояснювати. Так, якщо ти косметолог, скажімо, з уровня косметології,
Якщо це гинекологи говоримо про гинекологію, ми настільки з вами, ви посмотрите, скільки у нас образований, здесь сидячих людей, ми стільки всього знаємо, що ми про двигатель будемо говорити, і про
ходовку, і про фільтра масла, і про косметологію, про гинекологію, ми про все будемо говорити, про трепанасу черепа ми тож будемо с патологоанатомом говорити, понимаєте, ми обо всем умеємо говорити,
тому що ми дофига чого знаємо, ми знаємо нас інформацією, висше крыше.
І це наш інструмент, розумієте, це руче, пулемет.
А, механик, ладно, ту-ту-ту-ту, от тебе твоя інформація, от тебе бізнесмен, от тебе тот чоловік, от тебе этот чоловік, менеджер, неважно, где, на какой позиції, айтишник, программы, коды писати, все
тому подобное.
Просто немножечко, понимаете, еще подготавливаемся, если там че-то не знаем, мы же еще подготавливаемся, мы же еще подготавливаемся к сесії, мы же еще, допустимо, или к разговору, да?
Ну, це що касається сесії.
Да, Оксаночка.
Я хотіла Анастасію дополнить, в плане, коли недостаточна інформація.
Це мій личний опит, коли тебе приглашають як консультанта,
і там, наприклад, що нам потрібно оптимизувати компанію,
тому що ми її використовуємо як інструмент, а не як компанію,
яка буде розвиватися.
І вот починається економія.
І мені кажуть, що ні, і тут зрезаємо зарплату, і тут зрезаємо, а тут беремо бухгалтера на аутсорсі.
І це недостаток інформації.
Я кажу, подождите, у вас є защита, наприклад, в компанії?
І вони кажуть, що ви там зберігаєте інформацію?
Тобто ви готові в аудиторську компанію віддати інформацію, при цьому ви платите більші гроші гроші за сохранність, а тут ви віддаєте.
І чоловік тут зразу вже включається і говорить, що дайте мене хорошого головного бухгалтера.
Це недостаток інформації, коли теряются люди.
Да, именно, клас, супер. Оксана, хотела отметить одну такую классную вещь касательно вас і вашого присутствия. Я позволю себе отметить её, потому что, когда ранее на первом второму модуле я слышала
ваши комментарии, они были невероятно ценные, но сейчас вы говорите более конкретно, чёткими, чёткими такими, чётко объясняете конкретно ситуацию.
І це так класно, ви себе не представляєте, вас не хочеться перебивати.
Ви робите це короче, ви робите це содержателні і структурні.
Дякую вам за це більше.
Дякую.
Хорошо, їдемо далі.
О, послати, скільки у вас смайликів!
Просто!
Так, хорошо, їдемо далі, повертаються до нашої презентарії.
Ви знаєте, пройшло, навіть часу не пройшло,
як ми сьогодні з вами говоримо,
але при цьому, мені кажуть, що пройшло вже півдня,
і настільки це класно, що ми ще навіть до практики не дійшли з вами.
Так, психологічна потреба бути почутим.
Це дійсно психологічна потреба, бути почутим.
Кожна людина має право бути почутим, якщо вона цього потребує.
І тому і є коучи, психологи, психотерапевти,
Тому і жива така наша професія, дуже класна, файна, чуйна, допомагаюча.
Дослідження Гарвардської школи бізнесу взяла тут 2014 рок.
Беру дослідження, які свіжі, не більше бажано, в рамках 10-12 рочків.
Люди, яких справді слухають, відчувають вищий рівень самоцінності та рішучості приймати рішення.
Ну, дійсно ж так, ну, якщо нас чують, де наша самоцінність? Вона зростає.
Де наша опора і контакт в собі? Він зростає, бо наша самоцінність зростає,
бо нас почули, не важливо, що ми там говоримо, воно важливо, в деяких випадках,
якщо це психологічна сесія, якщо це робоча, якщо це бізнес, так,
І також, якщо це дома, на кухні, це теж важливо, так? Я не маю права обіцінювати, не важливо з точки зору, чого конкретно. Але наша самоцінність, наш контакт з собою, наша опора в собі, вона зростає,
вона починає.
Ти починаєш дихати, ти маєш крила. Навіть 15 хвилин слухання без перебувань створює відчуття, мене поважають, я важлива, звісно. Особливо, коли жінка слухає чоловіка або чоловік слухає жінку 15 хвили
н в день, ти такий думаєш, блін, з 12 часів робочих, так, треба виділити все ж таки ці 15 хвилиночок, щоб зростити цю саму самоцінність.
І тут ми йдемо до практики. 20 хвилинок у нас практика. Якраз практика і підемо на перерву. Тобто, зараз я вам поясню практику і потім на перерву десь хвилинчика.
Слухання без інтерпретації. Дивіться, шановні колеги, друзі, дівчатка, хлопчики, перший учасник ділиться внутрішнім реальним запитом.
Зараз, поки, я вже оговорю, вже розказую, сформуйте, формуйте, ви вже навчені, ви вже знаєте, що до мене приходимо з запитом.
У кожного з нас є багато запитів. Я знаю, що вони дуже широкі. Я знаю, що це не на годинку, не на дві. І це дійсно таке, що треба вирішувати, вирішувати. Але я вам, знаєте, що рекомендую? Нам з вами
ще навчатися і навчатися. Беріть один запит і от вам терапія безкоштовна на рік з відгуками і супервізією. Розумієте?
Блін, це фарт просто, це клас, і ще й в супроводі, і ще й стільки ма спеціалістами, це не тільки я можу ваш запит розбирати, це може розбирати і Юля Козачкова, це може і Віталій, це може і Влада розб
ирати, і все це один ваш запит.
Тож отак пошматовуйте його на кусочечки, пошматовуйте.
І внідряється, коли ми з вами працюємо.
Правда, ваші сесії не один раз на тижні, а один раз на місяць будуть умовно.
Розумієте, про що я кажу? Ви розумієте?
Не чую?
Так, так, добре, добре.
Тож зараз беремо цей клаптик вашого запиту.
Якщо він миленький, це може буде наклаптик. Буде наступна практика, ви бачите свій презентай, там теж у нас є запит. Буде завтра практика, теж буде запит. Враховуйте ці хвилиночки і розподіляйте, і
просто приймайте цю цінність як ще бонус від цього навчання.
Бо це найкласна практика.
Перший учасник ділиться внутрішнім реальним запитом 2-3 хвилиночки.
Часовий розподіл у нас по 10 хвилин на кожного учасника.
Робота в парах, тож 10 хвилиночок на одного, 10 хвилиночок на другого.
Аліна, враховуйте ту ситуацію, щоб не зливатися з клієнтом.
Щоб не зливатися, шукайте ту опору в собі, шукайте той контакт, той самий.
щоб не зливатися і щоб мати змогу від'єднатися.
Другий слухає, не перебуває, не запитує, не пояснює.
Потім відображає лише те, що почув без інтерпретації.
Повертає такі, так?
І потім обмін ролями.
Бачу чат, відкриваю.
Мене з постерігачем, будь ласка, ще в роботі частково, ага, а, ви пишете, добре, розумію, добре, так, друзі, виходимо, чи все ясно, все зрозуміло,
Ми сьогодні дуже класно
На цю тему говорили
Я думаю, що це дуже
Должно бать для вас просто
Понятно, главное вложитися
В 10 минут, здесь ми тренируем
Позиція коуч
Здесь ми тренируем
Ситуацию
Со временем, здесь мы
Тайм менеджмент наш тренируем
10 минуток
Не забывайте об этом
10 минут
Здесь ми тренируємо контакт з собою, селф-дискавери
Помните об цьому, що в першу чергу ми...
Здесь ми тренируємо всі рівні слушання
Понимаєте?
І беремо відсюду опит
Добрий час, заходимо
Я по обичаю буду потихонечку к кожному присоединяться
Не обращайте на мене внимання
Если я зашла, я зашла просто вас услышать, послушать
І лучше вас понять, хто куда идет, хорошо?
Просто не реагуються.
Хорошо.
Юлечка, ви видите,
хто йде в кімнату,
хто не йде в кімнату.
Найкращий результат – це дати глибину
в цьому процесі? Чи який найкращий результат
цієї сесії?
Найкращий результат –
це,
коли ви
відображаєте
лише те, що ви
почули,
як відзеркалили
Без глибокої інтерпретації, але ви почули, ви відображаєте для клієнта, і таким чином клієнт, найкращий результат, коли клієнт каже, да, блін, це про мене, це має, да, ви мене зараз зрозуміли, да, ви
іменно так мене зрозуміли.
Через метафори, його словами, яким способом це зробити.
Так, відображайте.
Чи будь-яким?
Яким вам завгодно, який хочете.
Добре?
Добре.
Так, я тут хтось ще пишу, що слухачем бажаю, я вас ще додаю.
І вже буду вимикати кімнати Анну ще і Катерину.
Клиночку.
Вісім, значить все.
є так
секунду
і вмикаю, відкриваю зали на 20 хвилин
ага, на 20 хвилин
тож ми заберемо трошечки часу
від перерви, довго я пояснювала
трошечки часу від перерви, ми здвинемося
на 10 хвилин, а потім на перерви, нічого страшного
ми сьогодні все встигнемо
добре
Добре? Всім зручно? Добре.
Ірина, а вас не додавати чи додати також слухачам?
Можна слухачем. Дякую.
У нас всі по троє будете четвертим слухачем.
Я сподіваюся, всі зрозуміли, що таке без інтерпретації.
Якщо що, я зайду і поясню.
Якщо хтось не...
Навіть по четверо.
Так, я вас зробила з організатором, щоб вас також не додавало в зали,
і ви можете до них також заходити, тому, тому, да.
Боже, дівчатка, я прогулялася зараз по залу.
Ми підемо на перерву, але був зал, де я просто досить мурашець.
Я розкажу, і якщо цей зал захоче поділитися, він поділиться.
Але в мене, я стільки відчула зараз, бо моя робота також відчувати, у мене ж голос тримтить від цього залу, реально мурашить.
Ні, ну так можна вже одразу, будь ласка, то ви нас заінтриговали, ми зараз уйдемо, як і є спокійно, є спокійно, піти чай, нельзя бити.
Ми згодні трішки подвинути перерву. Я думаю, всі згодні.
Дуже цікаво, дуже цікаво.
Це третій зал. Там я відчула ось це, що було в завданні без інтерпретації.
Третій зал. Ви себе знаєте. Ви хочете винести цю історію?
Так, це я. Я скажу більше, я заходила, я Наталичці кажу, чесно, у мене вже запити просто закінчились, ну, типу, такі актуальні, я просто в процесі, да, там, отримала повідомлення, і тут же в процесі
через це повідомлення починаю просто говорити, проговорювати ті емоції, да, воно там, вони стосуються,
Батька моїх дітей, я скажу чесно, я коли починала це говорити, я не думала, що в мені стільки емоцій, і я просто Наталці, знаєте, як в потоці, ти просто говориш, говориш, говориш, наговарюєш, це які
сь навіть не дуже зв'язні,
Тобто там про мої стосунки з чоловіком, там про стосунки його як батька до дітей, мої стосунки з моїм батьком.
І Наталці насправді вона витягнула чітко за півтори хвилини ту емоцію, яку я відчувала і просто слова викидала.
А вона просто оце все згрупувала і суть витягнула і озвучила. Це було прям мега сильно, правда?
Дякую. Озвучила Наталка не тільки озвучила. Наталя Нуця, ви не тільки озвучили, ви повернули без питання, без інтерпретації.
Ви обіняли свого собеседника,
ви обняли її на расстоянии настільки,
що аж мене замурашило.
Вот настільки ви її обняли.
Вот це і є присутствие, це є слушання.
Ми завтра будемо ще в присутствие углубляться,
вербалику, не вербалику.
Вот це є, це саме слушання.
І коли ти чоловіка, ти розв'якаєш йому настільки його ж.
Ви повернули і силу, ви повернули і енергию.
Ви дали підтримку за такий короткий проміжуток час.
А представляєте, час сесії.
І в цей час обязательно цю компетенцію внедрять.
Я вас умоляю, внедряйте її.
Це клієнт, це і в бесіде з другом, це в бесіде дому, з дітьми, з вашими дітьми, в вашій семье, це вже працює.
Ви возвращаєте людину його опору, ви возвращаєте його фундамент, ви возвращаєте його контакт з собою до мурашок. Благодарю, до мурашок.
Так.
Це просто те, що я хотіла озвучити.
Наша ціль — це не довести до слез.
Прямо слези клієнта — це слези клієнта.
Нет.
Це зайти в сердце клієнта, зайти в сердце вашого собеседника.
Просто там його обняти, просто взяти і сказати, я з тобою, я тут.
Через ваш возврат.
Так, я хочу додати, емоція піднялась, тобто сльози не тоді, коли я розповідала, від слова зовсім.
Емоція піднялась, коли вже Наталя почала мені повертати. Це правда.
Так, так, так. Ось ця практика, це була її ціль. Не питання, не питання, а ціль услышати.
Ми по кусочку собираем, ми по кусочку собираем по чуть-чуть, по чуть-чуть наработочки для наших сессий, да, і важно, вот завтра будем разбирать, важно, когда мы зайдем в присутствие, понимать, где ст
оп, где хватит, потому что вы можете увезти клиента, он, вашего собеседника, он на два часа уйдет в саморефлексию, и дальше будет только вот, да, вот это вот.
Тому дають 10 минут. Возьміть їх, використовуйте їх з цією силою.
Це я хотіла поділити. Дякую.
Дякую.
Уходимо на перерівок.
Возвращаємся через 10 минуточок.
Все успеем, у нас буде впереди демо-версія. Жду вас.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Так, потроху повертаємося.
Повертаємося потрошечки, потрошечки.
Повертаємося.
І так, продовжуємо.
Так, продовжуємо.
А тепер продовжуємо з саморефлексії, з рефлексії після праці, після практики.
Аліна, як ви себе відчуваєте зараз?
Клас, супер, супер, супер.
Ну що ж, шановні колеги, розкажіть, будь ласочка, який зал хоче виступити і сказати, що було для вас найскладнішим в цій практиці?
Що змінилось, коли вас просто слухали?
І чи було бажання додати щось від себе?
Я можу трошечки дозволити собі вгадати, що було бажання додати щось від себе?
Ось, так?
Ділимось.
Хто готовий?
Чий зал готовий вийти і сказати, що було найскладніше, що змінилось, коли вас просто слухали.
Чи було бажання додати щось від себе.
Клас, супер. Ще хочу додати одну-одну таку ремарочку.
Якщо я заходжу в зал, шановні колеги, я привид, ви мене не бачите, не чуєте.
Я можу перервати, щоб це було найефективніше. Я це роблю, але роблю лише для того, щоб ви тут в моменті зробили цю пам'ятку собі і зрозуміли, так, як я рухаюся далі. Це буквально 20-30 секунд. Так,
це буває. Так, це потрібно. Наразі це потрібно. Добре? Я привод. Я зайшла, я почула, я відмітила і пішла собі далі. Добре? Клас. Ділимось.
Наталя.
Мені перше було, думаю, на три хвилини розтягнути запит.
Зазвичай, коли приходиш, чітко вже сформовано раз,
а тут треба було на три хвилини розтягнути запит.
Це була перша важкість.
А друга, коли Аліна мені повертала, я з таким захопленням думаю,
вау, це так класно.
І я так думаю, а якщо в мене не вийде,
коли мені потрібно буде повертати Аліні, а я не зможу.
У мене отут був страх. Чесно, коли я її слухала, не було бажання щось добавити.
Єдине, коли вона сказала, хочеться плакати, я сказала, плач.
Все, це єдине, я таки вставила свої 5 копійок.
Але коли вона розповідала, не хотілося її доповнювати, не хотілося оцінювати.
Тому що коли людина вигружає, тут думаєш, вставляти свої 5 копійок – це взагалі не в тему.
хотілося дати можливість їй максимально
це вигрузити, щоб вона сама дійшла
до тієї суті, бо вона
починала з тої фрази, що я вже
не знаю, з яким запитом заходити,
і коли вона почала вигружати,
і я бачу, що вона доходить до тієї
точки, хотілося ще просто часу,
щоб їй вистачило того часу,
щоб вигрузити те, що вона насправді
всередині неї був.
Ось, так.
Дякую, дякую, Наталя. Далі
поговоримо, я розкажу,
як можна себе зупинити
в цьому моменті, що треба робити.
Далі розкажу, в слайдах в мене написано.
Скажіть, будь ласка,
так, чи хтось піднімає руки,
чи я питаю рандомно?
Питаю рандомно.
Був ще один зал,
який мене
зацепив. Анна.
Анна Король.
Так, це я.
Це я.
Розкажіть, будь ласка, свою історію.
Що було найважче?
Я вас перебивала. Я вибачаюсь.
Я просто говорю.
Не входіть в цю позицію
і не задавати питання.
Так. Хочеться, так?
Задати якесь питання.
Хочеться, хочеться щось, щось, щось запитати.
Углубити, да.
Да, углубити хочеться
розмышлення
клієнта своєго.
Дякую, дякую.
Я розкривала.
Я відмітила, я сказала,
Дуже класно, ви так класно зайшли, ви почули тембр голоса свого співбеседника, це була Тетяна, Тетяна Артемова, вона була, ви почули її тембр, і ви так класно зайшли, і мені, вибачте, так хотіло сказ
ати, тільки не питай, я про себе так кажу, тільки не питай, продовжуй, тільки не питай.
Тому я зійшла. Дякую велике. Таня, є щось сказати?
Так, я хочу додати, що Аня, коли повернула, задала мені питання, я просто знала, що ця практика без питань.
І я так віднеслася до цього питання, як ніби це просто, вона дає мені паузу і простір, щоб я сама над цим подумала.
і не маю зараз відповідати.
Вона якусь таку думку в мені запустила всередині,
а кому це треба?
І я така і пішла вже думати.
Тобто я відчула, що цей простір був,
і це також частина активного слухання.
Тут відчувалась, тому мені було дуже класно.
Якщо казати про мою роль коуча,
то найскладнішим для мене було якраз не задавати питання.
От були такі моменти, коли прям дуже хотілося уточнити або там, а про що це для тебе? От завжди хотілося. Тому, да, тут є такий момент.
Клас, дякую. Дякую велико. Наша завдання – запам'ятати одну таку річ. Не завжди клієнт приходить з запитаннями. Не завжди.
Є час для того, щоб дати йому простір.
В мене в практиці було неодноразово така ситуація, коли клієнт сам розказує, я вникаю, я вербалікою, не вербалікою, вникаю, підтримую.
І коли клієнт відчуває цю тишу, коли твій співбесідник відчуває цю тишу, знаєте, що він каже, в мене це було, він каже, блін, я зараз взагалі сам розумів, я зараз сам зрозумів, я відповів на всі свої
питання зараз, а я так не хочу.
І він сам дійшов до рішення, а я так не хочу далі, я хочу інакше. І от тоді ми накидемо ці питання, а як ти хочеш інакше? І пішло, от така енергія, от таке поле здається, і ти розумієш, ось це так, і
це для тебе як мед, просто він обтікає, і ти так розумієш.
Як казав Юрій, як казав, ти роздягнув клієнта у цей момент, ти дійсно його оголив, метафорично ти його оголив, бо ти створив для нього цей простір, цю тишу, і клієнт оголився і таки каже, а я так не
хочу, ось це я є, і тоді ми ймо далі.
Так, дякую.
Так, Ана.
Зараз хочеться процитувати Віталія, який говорив, я так уважно слухав свого клієнта, що він сам себе почув.
Так, так, так, так, бо він сам себе чує, бо він відчуває ваш простір і він сам себе чує. Клас, клас, супер.
Хто провелив задання, хто написав в чаті мені? Я провелив, я провелив тоді.
Юрій, я не почув, що треба без питань, дякую за вашу рефлексію.
Так, так, Юрій, так. Нічого, все ок. Ми тут для цього, щоб навчитися цьому. Все-все ок. Добре. Дякую, Юрій. Чи є ще у когось якась така рефлексія? Розкажіть, будь ласка. Чи вдалося? Оксаночко, щось
ви мовчите.
Я? Так.
Чи вдалося вам? Що було найскладніше?
Але у мене, як у клієнта, було складно, і це, скоріше, образ мушування,
тому що я, хоч і недолго була в терапії, і мені розуміли, що це мій образ мушування,
який людям понятен тільки при длітельному общіній зі мною,
і людей, які зразу розуміють, їх дуже просто мало.
Те, які при дліттенні, вони вже тоді видять, вони ориентируються, то мене було складно об'яснить,
тому, як там коучи, чи як назвати Олю, яка со мною була в цьому залі,
тому не она не змогла сформулировати, понять, внесла інтерпретатию, а я не змогла донести.
Оля, а ви можете сказати, що вам було найскладніше, коли ви повертали Оксані?
Да, могу. Во-первых, мне действительно було тяжело понять. Я, наверное, більше себя слухала, чем Оксану. В какой-то момент начала примерять на себя.
Поэтому здесь моє стопроцентне активне слушання не удалось. Я не почувствовала клиента на все стопроцентне.
Але мене і складно було сконцентруватися, то є я чувствувала, що в якісь моменти я випадаю.
Точно також, коли я...
Трішки вибу булася.
Да, розфокусування, але я навіть знаю, що це розфокусування, я її відслідила, що вона була в моменті, да.
Плюс мене було складно, саме задання, розуміла, що це пересказ потрібен, чи що, розумієте?
Тобто мені хотіло задати питання, мені хотілося углубитися, але я розуміла, що я не можу, я попыталась інтерпретувати, не от мене, Оксана, дякую вам, на Ритуля Оля, ми тут без інтерпретачі, ти должна
проговорити то, як ти мене услышала.
Ну, в общем, було сложно.
Окей.
Оля, спеціально для цього випадку у нас буде далі демо-версія.
Демо-версія, де я буду показувати, як я буду повертати.
Дякую.
Добре.
Так, ідемо далі.
Ідемо далі.
Чи є? Є хтось, кому було дуже важко себе відчути в цій сесії, от зовсім не розумів, що треба робити далі?
Де губилися? Де було відчуття в тілі? Ніхто не губився.
Так, добре. Юлія Кравчук, ви були учасником?
Так, була участникам.
Скажіть, будь ласка, що змінилося, коли вас просто слухали?
Ну, як будто бы вот эта тишина, да, которая є, дає мене ще більше понимання того, що я говорю, осознання того, що я говорю.
Класс.
Ну а слушать, кстати, я була удивлена, но слушать і нічого не спрашивати, і никак не аналізувати там, да, грубо говоря, було дуже легко мне.
Класс, клас.
Я просто слушала внимательно, що она говорить, і нічого не хотілося спросити, просто хотіла послушати.
Можна бути тому, що вона сказала, що мені хочеться зараз выговоритися,
але мені подобається, я відследила це за собою, мені подобається.
Дякую, дякую. Добре, що ж, йдемо далі, далі ще цікавіше.
І так, далі у нас що допомагає слухати клієнта?
Це фокус, це той самий фокус, тілесність, темп, увага і невірбаліка, що допомагає коучу в ці моменти сповільнення внутрішнього свого темпу.
Хто казав там, я не змогла, я не зміг сфокусуватися, мені хотілося, мені хотілося дати щось, привнести щось. Оце допомагає коучу також, вимкнення внутрішнього коментатора, порадника, довіра до нашої
тиші, відчуття емоцій, інтонації, пауз та чутливість до жестів, до міміки, до дихання.
І здатність витримати оце «не знаю», оце я зараз нічого не знаю, я тільки слухаю.
Справжній коуч, він не слухає відповідь, він слухає клієнта, який себе зараз, коли говорить в цьому процесі, він себе шукає.
Сповільнення внутрішнього темпу.
Коуч, котрий біжить поперед батько в пекло, він не чує.
Він тоді хитається, бо він не чує, бо він шукає сразу відповіді.
Він намагається сразу дати якісь відповіді.
А слухання починається не з клієнта, а з оповільнення себе, з контакту з собою, з дихання, з постави, з паузи, з того заземлення.
Так? Коуч – це не контейнер, це дві гон.
І ось тут про Наталя, коли ви давали відгук, я собі зробила поміточки Наталі Носе.
Цей момент – це коли ви десь промайнула така думка, що ви зараз не знаєте,
або щось зараз вас відволікає.
Вдих на 4, видих на 6.
Три секунди мовчання перед першою реплікою.
Це робиться дуже швидко, дуже швидко, ви вдихаєте, один, два, три, чотири, спробували, видихнули, все, ок, три секунди, дві секунди вам буквально на ось цю от це займе, оскільки 4 плюс 6 плюс 3 там,
10 яких секунд, 13 секунд для того, щоб ви включилися, це практика для уповіднення.
Ви так сповільняєтесь і ви краще розумієте свого співбесідника. І це веде до перемикання уваги з «я» на «ти». Мозок тобі каже, що я зараз скажу, а що як я не можу, а як бути корисним.
А коучингове слухання починається там, де я, відходить на задній план.
Фокус не, що я з цим зараз буду робити, а що в цьому я є для нього.
Ми вимикаємо просто внутрішнього коментатора.
Ну, це все ще не раз звучало, я б на ній місці зробила так, то якщо так, то так, то ми інтерпретуємо.
і це вимикає.
Коли ми вимикаємо,
ці думки, коли є
коментатор, він позбавляє
простору. Коуч, він не коментує,
він відзеркалює, він залишає цей
простір живим для всіх.
Так? Слухати, це не
завжди бути про
розумність,
це бути наразі
порожнім. І тут у нас
є також невеличке
дослідження. Юніверситі
коледж Лондон. Я тут і
На жаль, не змогла поступити, але, візможно, ще я попитаюсь.
Тиша – це активна присутність, тиша – це запрошення.
Так ось, клієнти в коучингу сприймали тишу по цьому дослідженню.
Після глибогого запитання, як емоційно підтримуючого, і понад 72% відчували, я можу подумати, мене не підштовкують.
Це, що ми відчуваємо з клієнтом.
Чутливість до інтонації.
До пауз, до невербаліки.
І ми слухаємо, як клієнт зітхає в моменті.
Чи подивився він вниз?
Чи почав щось теребіти в руках?
Чи змінив позу, бо йому стало незручно зараз?
Може, він занадто часто тримає себе за лице,
може щось почихує нос та підборіться,
може щось тримає себе за шею, за горло,
Десь якось міняється, це теж фізіогноміка, це теж є для вас маркером, як зчитувати, як відчувати цю паузу вашого клієнта.
Пам'ятайте, внутрішнє порожнече як простір для клієнта, коуч, як кімната без медлів, у яку клієнт приходить і чує себе.
Якщо в кімнаті багато коуча, клієнта там не буде.
Він буде тільки на завданні, що йомусь зараз питання.
Так, так, так, так, так, так, так, так, так, і все.
Так?
Добре.
Ще у нас є практика, в котру ми зараз заходимо.
Потім у нас буде демо-версія на наступну практику.
Поглиблене слухання з невербалікою.
Де учасник ділиться темою, коуч слухає, відображає не слова, а зараз, т.е. того разу ви відображали, ви повертали, як ви зрозуміли клієнта словами, його словами ви повертали.
Наразі ви відображаєте не тільки слова, якщо вдасться, можна не слова зовсім, а зміни в стані, в голосі і в тілі.
Ось тут важливо зануритись.
Коли... Пробуємо ще раз.
Оля, ця практика, Оля Богдановська, буде дуже класна для вас.
Ще раз. І пам'ятаємо, 4-6. Вдих, видих. Так? Якщо ви слухаєте і зрозумієте зараз, що вас виносить, вдихаєте, видихаєте, вдихаєте, видихаєте. Добре?
А можна питання?
Звісно.
Получається, клієнт розповідає свій запрос, а коуч нічого не дає, крім того, що він має записати, що він побачив?
Так, він не записує.
Ви повертаєте голосом, але акцентуєте вашу увагу на ціло, на голос, на стан.
Так? Зрозуміло?
Це в моменті, коли перебивати чи дочекатись до кінця?
Дочекатись, ви будете повертати.
А як тоді не записувати, якщо клієнт може говорити 2-3 хвилини, ми можемо трошечки...
Ні-ні-ні, питання було таке, чи голосом, чи записувати.
Ви можете як завгодно вести смісл.
Як завгодно.
Потім, коли повертаєте, зараз завдання.
Тоді було завдання розказати, повернути.
А зараз акцент, ви розказуєте, повертаєте,
але акцентуєте на тому, як змінився стан, де.
А я почула, коли ти говорила зараз про це,
наприклад, коли ти говорила зараз про дітей,
В тебе голос став такий більш роздратований або більш тихіший.
А тут ти змінила свою позицію.
Бо коли ми відмічаємо, клієнт, коли розказує, він не помічає, що він робить.
Він не завжди помічає.
99,9 він не помічає, що він робить.
Але його тіло, його голос, його стан, яким він себе позиціонує в фізіогномиці, емоції, лице, він себе видає.
Ось це є акцент наразі, щоб ви побачили.
Добре? Без питань.
Ми продовжуємо цю практику з акцентом поглибження.
Без питань. Старайтесь не запитувати.
Старайтесь побачити і цей простір ось просто створити, створити для клієнта.
Добре?
Так.
І ще в мене питання до організаторів.
Будь ласка, скажіть, я бачу, що багато хто пише, що мене слухачем, мене спостерігачем, будь ласка.
Якщо можна, було б класно, щоб було парами, так?
Ну, в нас, тому що багато хто хоче як слухач, вони не будуть брати участь в цій практиці.
І я роблю, тобто я їх додаю третіми, а пари будуть працювати.
Добре, добре. Так, добре. Заходимо по 10 хвилиночок на кожного, це 20 хвилин.
Оглиблюємось, а далі будемо розмовляти, розмовляти більше, більше, більше, що вдалося, що не вдалося.
Дайте цих мурашок, видайте, хто пішов з цим запитом, який у вас там десь є, давайте його.
Давайте, продовжуйте його, добре?
Я відкрила зали.
Дякую, Велика.
І Юлія Байченко.
Дякую за перегляд!
Так, мені класно сьогодні, слухайте, я не можу.
Я просто переглянула вчора свої слайди і кажу, Боже, Лана, ти реально це все написала?
Боже, це так зв'язно? Клас, супер!
Я теж переглядала, дуже такі цікаві. Десяті кімнаті, три спостерігача.
Розкидуємо.
Давайте. Ніхто не може працювати, я в шоці. Спорище Юлія.
Цікаво, чому?
Я бачу дуже класний отклик сьогодні.
Ми це зараз винесемо на селф-дискавері.
Яка класна тема.
Зараз винесемо на селф-дискавері, де загубилася позиція коуч.
Бо якщо задавати питання, всі задають питання.
А от якщо послухати, тут є питаннячка.
Так, давайте я їх розпреділю до 15 кімнатів.
це куди я тут порозпреділяю, тому що сята, переймось і дев'ята кімната, і восьма, напевно,
Ми сьогодні прям будемо відточувати, прям відточувати, відточувати, відточувати,
бо загалом часто люди думають, що ми вміємо слухати, але це не всіх так.
Ну, так. До речі. Ну, а як вам, взагалі, проводити на вечірні, а такі ранішні лекції?
Мені кайфово.
Так.
Так, вибачте, дуже лису шоколадку.
Мені кайфово, бо я знаю, що о першій годині дня я все, я закінчила.
І в мене є ще три ролика на YouTube записати.
В мене є час просто до гори.
Ой, клас. Ви на YouTube записуєте ролики?
Угу.
Ну, ви многогранна личності, просто.
Юля, мій тренер сказав мене, говорит, Лана, тут ти,
говорит, істерва, тут ти, сука, тут ти, говорит, ти барыга
какая-то, тут ти леди, тут ти психолог, а тут ти матерішся.
Говорю, ти просто невероятно многогранна.
Говорю, і актриса просто, наверное, по житні.
Ну так, до сьогодні, Тріся, це точно.
У нас є 15 хвилин, тому ми можемо переривчик або потім по кімнатах позаходити, глянути, що там в кого.
Я зараз піду по кімнатах, бо хочу дуже розуміти, наскільки вони розуміли.
По наступному у нас є останнія практика, там буде демо-сесія, і в цій практиці я прям буду показувати,
тому що я вижу, що многие мають затык, що таке відследити мимику, що таке відследити вообще
чоловіка в моменті, що с ним відбувається.
Вот, тому
я пойду
позахожу і посмотрю, що с ним відбувається.
Где, то, де.
Да, без проблем.
Дивіться, спілкуємо дуже.
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Так, добре, повертаємося.
Поїхали. Ми закріпляли.
У нас буде, як я казала, ще демо-версія.
Ми ще її більш уточнюємо.
А зараз скажіть мені, що вам вдалося в цей раз? Розкажіть.
Расскажіть. Оля Богдановська, хочу вас спросити.
Ладно, але мені показалося, що в цей раз легше. Гораздо, я сама розслабилась, вдох-відох помог.
і я пыталась тотально слушать, чувствовать і, да, ну, іногда не хватало...
Вот, как будто, как будто бы, вот, не хватало слов, чтобы описать состояние напротив меня,
которое я считывала.
Я себе сделала заметочки в том, что вы замечали, мне так нравится, я озвучу их для
Тож всіх участників, як ви говорили, плечи піднялись, тело заіграло.
Прямо такими словами вже інтерпретували.
Я прочла в твоїх глазах некоторе несогласие, я увидела радість в твоих глазах.
І я в цей момент вже розуміла, що ви включилися, ви прям інтерпретували, що відбувало.
Це було класно.
Ви возвращали то, що ви видели.
І мені було важливо, тому що ви задали питання, я зацепилася за цим.
Мені було важливо, щоб ви зашли в цей процес і змогли услышати, змогли відповідати.
Тому що є, кстати, є, дійсно, спеціалісти, які більше можуть розвращати невербалику.
І це нормально, і це теж нормально.
Це теж хорошо. У вас це класно сталося.
Спасибо вам огромное.
Спасибо.
Я кайфанула, правда.
Класс, супер, отлично.
Веже роки.
Ирина Копчик.
Я думала, що це буде легше.
Тому що після першого разу я була слухачем,
потім там пояснила дівчатам,
і мені здавалося вже потім обґрунтували все.
Вау, то це ж так просто.
І коли ми зайшли і почали,
я почала слухати,
І потім це повернення, ніби десь всередині я розумію, що відбувається.
Я ніби бачу, але як словами передати потім це все без інтерпретації, без підказок, без запитань, без нічого.
Особливо, коли людина каже, що я не знаю, хочеться наводячі якісь запитання ще додати, це нелегко.
І потім так само якраз і про те, що коли вже я мала виговорюватися,
і потім коли мені почали показувати мою невербаліку,
і в мене такі як інсайди, тому що вже в принципі те, що я говорила,
то я знаю, де в мене там є, що десь я стискаюся,
але що це так видно, як воно все змінюється,
Як в мене тіло рухається, як руки, як голос міняться.
Тобто, я ніколи не думала, що в другому так все класно вчитуватися може.
Це теж такий вау-інсайд для мене.
Дуже класно.
Так, так, я прям відчуваю вас з кожною клітинкою.
Так, ви дійсно спочатку кажете, ой, це так легко, це так легко.
А коли ти повертаєш, так і думаєш, а що, а де я була в цей момент?
Ось це про контакт з собою.
А де я була?
Ось як Оля сказала, каже, вдох-видох,
він мені помог.
Де я була? Оцей контакт.
Клас, дійсно, супер, супер.
Дякую, дякую велико.
Так, бачу. Ага, Аліна.
Аліна Віліхіна.
Ну, я хочу сказати,
якщо чесно,
настільки здавалось би просто,
так як, ну, от, ти дивишся,
ти маєш послухати і маєш просто
грубо кажучи повторити те що людина сказала але о той ефект від оцього повернення після першого
всі всі поняли ефект відчули на мені я вдруге дуже старалась не заплакати я вже думала якщо
я заплачу все я цей все кажу я сьогодні не вчуся і сьогодні плачу ну насправді і знову ж таки
І я отой дотрик, я хотіла розказати спочатку як коуч, добре, скажу спочатку як клієнт.
Я відчула завдяки поверненню, завдяки тому, наскільки мені Таня підсвічувала мою мову жестів, мою мову тіла.
Навіть де я сповільнювалася, де я швидше говорила.
І от навіть на цих моментах в мене були інсайти.
Тобто я сповільнювалася в тих моментах, де я ще раз проживала ту ситуацію, взяла той самий запит, здавалося б все те саме, але я наново прожила.
І як зі сторони коуча, класно. В якийсь момент я розумію, що воно інтуїтивно в мене було, але я йому не надавала такого значення.
А коли я цілеспрямовано людину слухала, спостерігала,
і потім я дійсно усвідомлено вже їй підсвічувала,
їй повертала оці моменти, і вона мені дає фідбак,
я розумію, да, ну, да, воно, тобто прям, да.
Дякую велике, Лена, це просто клас.
Дякую.
Я хочу наголосити, Аліна, я хочу наголосити також для всіх учасників,
для всіх студентів, будь ласка, ви пам'ятайте і запам'ятайте, все, що робиться в Вегасі, залишається в Вегасі.
У нас тут все конфіденціально. Ми нічого, нікуди, ніхто не вносимо. Це наш процес.
Ми тут создаємо то саме пространство, де ми піднімаємо найбільні теми.
Це як коучингові сесії. Ми з вами заключили вже цей контракт на етапі начала обучення.
Тому все, що тут відбувається, не забувайте о том, як Татьяна теж обратила увагу на це, що «Наверно, я буду розкрывати, да було б не класно, було б класно, розкрывайтеся». Раскрывайтеся здесь, обсужд
айте, це для вас найбільше пространство для вашої психотерапії, для тех больних моментів, які ви хочете сказати.
Ви просто об'язані вийти з цього обучення з лігкостю,
тому що ви взяли не просто інструмент,
ви його попробували на себе.
Ви його на себе ощутили, як це роботає.
Тому все, що тут відбувається в Вегасі.
Це найважливі.
Дальше. Хорошо, да.
Спасибо більше, Алина.
Анна.
Я как раз хочу вернути вам ваші коментарі
поводу спеціалістів, які считають невербаліку, я, скоріше згодом,
якраз цей специаліст. Я не праудіал, я візуал, я ощущаю енергетику,
я чувствую настроєння, я вижу мимику. І для мене считати чоловіка
по його емоціям намного проще, ніжле просто слушати внимателно.
Я не знаю, там сейчас Василий буде комментировать,
може б мене, може б себя, не знаю, но у нас класний диалог получился.
Супер, я слышала про другий наш диалог, всіх сейчас буде интересно.
Да, клас. Анна, ви правы абсолютно, є визуалі, є аудиалі, є кінестетіки,
Которые ощущають, как, де, что, да?
І ви правы, абсолютно так і є.
Пока не забыла, хочу вам порекомендовать
Фильм «Light to me» «Совремня».
Смотрели кто-нибудь фильм «Light to me»?
Да, Валерия, знаю, клас!
Супер, супер, накидайте плюсики, если кто смотрел.
Напишите себе, на русском языке называется «Совремня»
или «Нелгимня», я точно не знаю, как на русском языке,
но на английском называется «Light to me».
Там играють роль дуже известні актёри, у мене пам'ять дуже плоха на імена, і це таке, но lie to me, значить, чому?
Да, теорія лжи, соврі мене, обмани мене, совершенно верно, да, спасибо, що поправили.
Значит, головний герой роботи в парі з клиническим психотерапевтом, а он физіогномик, он считывает.
Сезонів там багато, але вам буде достатньо буквально, мені на самому діля, там де-то, коли интересно, я туди возвращаюсь, тому що весь вопрос физіогномики, хто що з'язав, хто з'язав губи, хто стиснув
зуби, у кого напряглись скулы, хто яким жестом, хто куда посмотрел, вам буде дуже класно це взяти для позиції коуч, поэтому возьміть, да, це серіал, там багато сезонів, скільки зможете, тільки посмот
ите, ви поймете для себе, о чому я говорю.
Пока не забыла, «Совремня». Классний фильм.
І є ще книга «Тело говорит». «Тело говорит». Я найду, хто автор.
Помню «Тело говорит», не помню автора, але обязательно вам скажу автора.
Для тех, хто читає.
Да, продовжуємо дальше.
«Сегодня», видите, як у нас? Вижу, вижу, Юра, вижу, вижу, щас.
Секундочку. «Сегодня у нас, видите, тема.
Ми по слайдам, в принципі, вернуться к слайдам,
ви понимаєте, що ми говоримо обо всім, що написано в слайдах.
І мені здається, що для вас цей честний, живой діалог
гораздо краще, ніж будемо читати лекцію по слайдам.
Согласны?
Да. Супер. Отлично.
Василий, пропустите Юрия?
Руку піднімав на світ.
Да, Юрий, говорите.
Я в тему серіала.
І коли обучення по НЛП проходив, у нас було здання смотреть серіал,
мы его смотрели без звука и просто задача была замечать отличие потому что в сериал можно думать
типа что это так а на самом деле нас вот на новичку вас тоже учат замечать отличие потому
что каждого человека каждый жест это что-то другое вот чтобы не интерпретировать это за
правду а научиться именно видеть вот и мы каждое утро по десять минут должны были просто смотреть
сериал и говорить вот та минута то та минута то та минута то рандомную любую серию вот такая
практика була.
Да, да, да, да, это не лингвистическое
программировання. В коучинге ми проходили, я не помню,
может, в первом, может, во втором модуле
я вам рассказывала. У нас была
сессия, у нас было задание
сессии, когда человек
ничего вообще не
говорит, вообще ничего.
Он просто озвучивает свой запрос,
а коуч наводящими
вопросами выводит его
на мимику, на жесты,
на невербалику, понимаете?
И вот важно было,
Оценить той момент, що дійсно коуч попадав в тему запроса клієнта.
Ось так ми проходили цю невербалику.
Ми її з вами тож будемо проходити, це буде позже,
коли ви прям возьмете інструменты прямо на всю силу.
І коли ви поймете, це були такі сесії дуже мощні,
коли ви розумієте клієнта без слов.
Ви знаєте, в общіні, в соціумі це так проявляється.
Ви коли розпочуєшся з людьми, ви просто розумієте, хто, що, де, о чому, з кем можна говорити, на кого ти тратиш час, на кого нет, з кем полезно, з кем нет.
Це дуже класна така тема. Спасибо, що підняли її.
Спасибо, Юрий.
Це дуже допомогло в діалогі з поліцією немецькою. У мене щось є телефон, вони мені з'явили телефон, і ко мене прийшла поліція з обіском.
І я бачив, що він мене обмануває, він врет мене в його голову.
Телефон якби використовують те же технології, але все, я мовчу.
Нет, дело в тому, що у вас в нього нестабильне підключення було би класно.
Можливо, на мобильний інтернет потім перейдете, щоб вас було більше слышно.
Спасибо большое. Да, Василий, поділитесь, пожалуйста, что получилось, как у вас. Я прям вижу ваши горящие глаза и вижу, вижу, что да, говорите.
Один з перших інсайтів – це було розуміння, що тиша моментом вибиває, і людина, чи це я, чи це клієнт, не будемо говорити,
Тобто десь хоче швидше спригнути, хоча є певний відрізок, але ні, типу все, кінець запиту, кінець запиту.
І в принципі в сесіях питання вони допомагають клієнту, вроді би, піти глибше, але тиша вона діє теж дуже круто.
Коли ти просто мовчиш і показуєш, продовжуй. Твій час є і тоді оця присутність наодинці, ну її не кожен витримає, але вона сама може дати багато відповідей.
І це було цікаво спостерігати. І теж моїм таким інсайтом прям прийшло, що колись я був достатньо, скажімо так, гіперактивний ІІ.
І зараз от в мене приходять такі фідбеки, що в квітні хто був зі мною на грікиш-флоу, я учасник, такий спокійний, я такий думаю типу, ну це про мене, в моїй голові завжди було, що я там Шилово десь
там і пішло-поїхало, і отут, коли я спокійно зміг витримати всі 9 хвилин в мовчанні, та провокуючи на відповідь, лише рухами продовжувати, я ще раз в хорошому сенсі слова вдягнув цю корону, що я можу
витримувати.
тишу. І що я і є цією тишою. Це для мене. А ще загалом такий інсайт. Ну, я накінець-то виговорився. Мій
основний запит був виговорити за сьогоднішній день, за тиждень. Типу, бо багато всього було. І от якогось такого
купати з неї. І мені було достатньо часу. Тобто, і я і вписався в час, і все решта. Тобто, я і набрався, і
спустошився в хорошому сенсі слова.
Тому дякую за цю можливість.
Клас, Васілій.
Я зрозуміла, що Анна в парі.
Це було клас.
Просто добре, дуже класно зіграли тут.
Кожен відіграв свою роль чудово.
Це те, що ми говорили в слайдах, в нашій презентації.
Тиша, тиша, тиша.
Коли коуч нікуди не біжить,
він має цю можливість бути самим тишою
для свого клієнта, це клас
клас, що ми це відпрацьовуємо
прям отак от наживо, дякую
дякую, дякую Анна, дякую Василь
спостерігала за вашою залою
мені сподобалось, клас
дякую
супер, це було і забавно, і смішно
і дуже працююче
і з інструментами
це класно, це було легко
дякую, йдемо далі
так, я бачила
Юля Печенка, я вас бачила теж
тому вертайтесь
А зараз Анастасія Вильноградова?
Я почала говорити дуже емоційно,
быстро-быстро-быстро-быстро,
і к концу успокоїлася.
І це теж считалось делом.
Мені зразу це підсвітили.
Я поняла, що весь цей хаос
упорядочився,
все розложилось по полочкам,
і к концу приходить таке спокійство,
в якому вже рождається то,
що може привести до результату.
Я дуже стала спокійна.
А в іншій ситуації мені проще,
правда, теж проще,
Считывать нерву балику
І наблюдається за телом
У мене в це час відключається мозк
І правда ні одній мисли нет
І зараз я навіть пробовала не слушати
Я половину разговора
Слов не передам
Але суть, о чому йдет річ
Я поняла просто по телу
Мене тоже проще тело считывать
Гораздо
Ваш собеседник подтвердил, що ви поняли, да, його?
Надеюсь, да
де мій собеседник не вижу, але вона так і сказала, що «да», «да», «да», так і, ну, по крайні мере, три разу я услышала «да».
Валерія Смолича була ваша собеседник, наскільки.
Да, Валерія. Просто не увижу її на екрані, ну, да, Валерія була.
Да, да, да.
Настенька, да, все дуже-очень четко почувствовала, може бути не в моменті, не там кажде слово могла там передати,
Але суть передана, і по тому, як двигалося моє тело, дуже чітко змогла описати ситуацію. Умічка.
Класс, отлично, спасибо. І ще у нас, да, Оксана Малютинка.
Я хотела додавити по поводу серіала, такий момент один коротко.
Там, коли приняли девушку в цю команду, он їй сказав, руководитель, що у тебе талант,
тому що ти це все научилася в дитині.
І виявилися, що у її був отец алкоголик, він приходив, і она считывала з нього.
І от він їй сказав, що ти прийшла з таким талантом, але тебе ще потрібні знання.
Це прям як нам.
Ми все тут прийшли з якимось своїм опитом, знаннями, і ще получаємо більше.
Спасибо за таку практику. Практика була отлична.
Спасибо. Спасибо большое.
Катя, Катя, Ендель.
Хотела поделиться, что вот когда началась сессия, я в ролі коуча була,
і задача ж наблюдать за жестами, за тоном,
і я понимаю, що в който момент я перестала її слухати.
Я настільки сконцентрировалась на тому,
що її миміка, жісти, і я включилася, і я така, стоп, подожди,
я, як будь-то, то, що вона говорила, це був фон.
Я себе остановила і така, так, віддыхаємо, відвращаємося, слушай,
тому що проблем в цьому немає, щоб считувати і слухати,
це завжди, як навык такий, і коли я така остановилась, віддохнула,
Я словила себе на це, і потім вже я її слухала, а считування вже було на автоматі. І після того, як я, вона закінчила, Ульяна закінчила, я з Ульяною работала, і она підтвердила то, що считала я
правильно.
І у неї дуже класно в миміці лиця, лоб, глиця, прям обо всім сказали.
Даже не ця частина, а лиця. Расслаблення, як вона напрягалась.
І вона сказала, що у тебе випадку, з її слов.
Але в момент, коли вона виключила слухання активне, і воно фоном, це було прям прикольно.
Знаєте, це як красна машина, і ти починаєш бачити тільки красну машину.
Тільки смотрий, а просто потрібно було ненашко себе повернути.
Прикольно було, класно. Випад, спасибо.
Зараз.
С язика сняли, Ульяна, отсутствие ботулотоксина на лицо.
Просто с язика сняли.
А тепер давайте поговоримо, мужчины, о том,
Ну як ви будете щитувати женщин, у которых очень много ботулотоксина.
Емоційно запросто, питань нема.
Емоційно, так.
Бо емоції, рухи, жести, це все видає.
Звісно, так є.
Але я можу сказати, Василь, є люди, які не дуже емоційні.
Є такі люди, не дуже емоційні, не дуже рухливі.
і дуже довго розхитуються на кшталт емоцій,
дуже довго і ти в деякий момент розумієш,
що перед тобою людина, яку важко розхитати.
Є ще тоді дихання іде, фактично, і тоді дії.
Дії ніхто не підміняв, рухання очей.
Тобто, можливостей багато, якщо робити цей рапорт,
скажімо так, і не боятись, то думаю, що це можливо.
Так, можливо, це можливо для тих, хто вже практикує,
вже ці навички якісь має, для новачків, бажано,
звертайте увагу на дихання, як рухається грудна клітина,
звертайте увагу на зрячки, куди дивлять глаза,
обращайте на це внімання, обращайте внімання на якісь качки тіла,
Могут бути ще такі качки тела. Типа, ну, ну, ну, вот так.
І ще таке може бути. Те, хто ще не знайом, не глупоко ушав в практику, обращайте теж на це внимание.
Оно є, і вроде б кажуть, що чоловік не буде. Вот такий, вот, він не играє, там тело не играє, емоцій нет.
Але є речі, які, да, обращайте на це внимание.
Слыша, є такі, як замираючі тела і покерфейс? Конечно, є, Настя Винага.
Як раз я о них розказую. Там є заморожені чувства, є заморожені емоції, чувства давним-давно, там все заморожено. Действительно, нейротипологія, Анна, согласна, есть такое, помогає, абсолютно соглас
на.
Поэтому ми говоримо, що є коучинг, там беремо що-то з клініки, з кліническої психології, там беремо що-то з філософії, там де-то беремо з нейролингвистичних практик, і тому ваш курс, він дуже мощний,
ваше обучення, реально дуже мощне.
Оно позволяет вам, дает возможность со всех сторон заглядывать, посмотреть на человека.
Очень класно. Супер. Я уверена, что вы чувствуете себя просто замечательно.
Посмотрите, как у нас классно сегодня хорошо проходит наша с вами беседа.
И двигаемся дальше. Двигаемся дальше. Спасибо огромное. Будем еще говорить.
Значит, здесь двигаемся дальше по слайдам. До слидження з Гарварду.
Що я хочу сказати? Є команда науковців, які довели, що невербальна поведінка коуча відкрита поза, уповільнений темп, м'який голос створює у клієнтів значно вищий рівень довіри.
І клієнти ставали дійсно відкритищами до самого усвідомлення до своїх змін.
І у нас 5 минулого перерыва.
Я хочу, щоб ви максимально сьогодні розгружались і розуміли, як це роботає.
Почему? Потому что наша нейронна система, да, она имеет нейросеть, наша нейросеть для того, чтобы закрепить опыт, должна иметь возможность немного 5-10 минут тишины, для того, чтобы вы его закрепляли
, поэтому мы внедряем чуть больше таких перерывчиков, чтобы вы закрепляли этот опыт, а не бежали, не перезагружали свою нейросеть.
Так вот, действительно, ви наверняка обращаєте увагу на кожного коуча, це, кстати, тож поднимає самооценку, кожного з вас, запомните, ви вже мощ, ви вже сила, ви, действительно, люди, на кого є, у
кожного є свої клиенти, кому-то тембр голоса «мій» підходить, кому-то он не підходить, кому-то моя внешність підходить, кому-то она не підходить, да?
І, відповідно, це інследування показує, що чим більше коуч в контакці з собою приймає себе в опорі на себе, лично на себе, він заходить в цю позицію коуч твірдо.
Допустим, є у нас багато таких моментів, я уверена, що у вас є таке, що сходи к моєму психологу, у мене є психолог, сходи к моєму психологу, він тебе допоможе, а ти туди йдеш і розумієш, що цей
человек не твій, це не твій типаж, це не твій голос, це не твій чоловік.
Просто говориш подруге, допустим, друзі там рекомендували, подруге говориш,
«Слушай, ну, все класно, но не подошел мне твой психолог, не обижайся».
Почему? Потому что здесь не всегда знания играют большую роль.
Еще очень часто играет, соответственно, позиция, вот эта коуч-позиция.
И тембр, и мимика, и как мы двигаемся.
Есть люди, которые хотят найти специалиста более экспрессивного или более энергичного.
а з наоборот того, хто буде медитативно його вводити в состояние спокійствия, да, і такі моменти часто-часто происходять, так, окей, що ж, ми з вами двигаємся далі, і на сьогодні у нас буде ще одна
практика з демо-версією, перед тим три минутки, як я вас відпущу на перерыв, демо-версія буде заключатися именно в цій практиці, я хочу пригласити,
Як наблюдателя
Здесь робота буде в трійках
Я хочу пригласить як наблюдателя
Для своєй демо-практики Юрия
Юра, ви не проти?
Я за
Аргументирую, тому що
Услышала от вас
Некий посыл, правильно ли я его поняла
Что ви хотіли б більше понимати
Что такое без інтерпретации
Работати, создавати тишину
Создавати пространство
видити невербалику
і не інтерпретувати, да?
Хочу, щоб ви
немножко понаблюдали, окей?
Як слышно, приємно?
Та, я все слышу прекрасно, я не понимаю, почему.
Я вас слышу.
І завис, да?
Я вас слышу, но не слышу.
Ну, попробуем,
во всяком случае, если что, напишите в чате.
Пишите заметки даже в чате.
Хорошо.
І хто б хотів бути моїм клієнтом на...
Василий, да, що?
Ви б хотіли клієнтку...
Ви сьогодні ще не виговорились.
Хорошо, Василий був першим.
Хорошо, хорошо.
Василий, якщо ви хочете, можете вступити.
Це ваше право, договорістись.
І пійдемо з вами в демо-версію буквально на нескільки минуток, а потім зайдемо в последнюю, крайнюю сьогодні практику для максимального закріплення сьогоднішній теми позиції, уровня слішення.
Окей?
Да, ви хотіли сказати, Василий, да?
Я спочатку хотів вступити, але потім думаю, ну раз я перший, то я граю.
Той виграєте.
Однозначно.
Добре.
Я б хотіла бути вашим, тож у вас, наблюдателем.
Давайте, без проблем, без проблем, наблюдателем давайте.
У нас можуть бути спостерігачі, можуть бути, можуть бути нескільки спостерігачів.
Поэтому, коли ви наблюдаєте, єдинственне, що ви можете і записувати, можете і в чаті писати, що ви отметили, що ви заметили, окей?
Вопрос наблюдається за клиентом или за коучем?
Ви наблюдаєте за коучем, як коуч ведет себя в коуч-позиції,
і так же параллельно все-таки отмечаєте і клиента.
Але задача клієнта основна, це моя, замість його.
Ваша задача – замість мене як коуча, як я заметила клієнта.
Здесь просто все маленькі, по-хорошому, кого замечаєш, вивезти большим одним, а двох нельзя большими вивезти.
Может, организатор може це зробити, щоб можна було наблюдається?
Нет-нет-нет, ми в цьому самому, ми здесь со всіми це будемо робити.
Я не можу поставити вас двох большими, щоб реально зробити.
Ви дуже маленькі, щоб фокусувати взгляд сразу на двох, тому спрашиваю, за кем наблюдається.
От в мене зараз, наприклад, до трьох видно, всіх трьох останніх, хто говорив.
Так, коли я презентацію приберуть, буде видно, буде коуча видно і клієнта.
Якщо це досить налаштування, такі, що там тільки докладчиків або чуть-чуть докладчиків.
Так, я взяв декілька докладчиків, видно трьох. Супер, дякую.
Так, добре, зараз йдемо трошки закріплювати нейросіті свої.
Десять мінут і повернутися.
Чого? Так! Я вже тут готовий. Ну добре. Закріпіть, не перегружайте мозку, закріпіть німножко. Окей. Василь, починай виговорюватися, ми будемо слухати. Ну ладно, віддихайте, віддихайте.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Ірина, ви теж одна залишилися тут?
Яка ще Ірина одна залишилася? Тут багато залишилася, але ми в тіні.
Ми тут просто перекушуємо щось.
Я не зрозуміла, це вже сесія чи це перерив?
Це перерив.
А я жду кімнату.
Сьогодні походить дуже цікаво, через то навіть ти не хочеш.
Не, я на фоні просто своє роблю, але...
не знаю нічого друзі сьогодні має багато має бути багато відгуків має бути дійсно багато тьфу блін я вже запінаюсь
Лан знаєш Лан можна не ти коли я тільки зайшов там в 17.40 бо я трошки переплутав години і я думаю блін якийсь новий спікер якийсь новий
Думаю, Ілана ж має бути. І твоя українська насправді для мене сьогодні була заворожуюча.
Це зовсім по-іншому. І хотілося б почути твою українською мовою і від тебе медитацію.
Тому що російською ти прям танцюєш дуже смачно. Хоча я інколи дергаюсь на російську, скажімо так.
Але українська для мене сьогодні вона вовше супер заворожуюча.
І тут не те, що якісь ярлики чи ще щось, а от прям дійсно.
Тому дуже смачно.
Прям включилась. Я прям включаюсь.
Слухай, дякую велике. Я дуже намагаюся, але що виходить, Василь.
Дуже складно три мови.
Англійською навчаюся, на рускому говорю вдома.
На рускому я мама воспітувала.
Ізучала всю інформацію дуже на русском.
Я намагаюся, мені подобається, але коли я щось хочу дійсно пояснити,
мені так робиться так.
Все, я зависла, я нічого не можу зробити.
Те, що я сьогодні чуюсь, я прям чую чисту мову.
Я так навіть не говорю, як ти, скажімо так.
Тобто ти коли думаєш, ти прям стараєшся її дати класною і чистою, і це смачно.
Ну, для мене особисто, ну, реально, бо отут, на західній частині України, саме от таку чисту мову, де не скофта, ну, не от з пішаком, ну, її важко почути.
Ну, для мене це реально було таке класне захоплення, однозначно. Тому дякую за твою спробу. Для мене це просто кигмет на душу.
Собі їхав в машині, ще слухав, так вау, так розслабляючи.
Це я допомню, тому що хто говорить, хто виріс російську мову, використовував дому і все, і вчить українську.
Мені є багато подруг зараз, це в Італії, і одна от з Полтави, в неї літературна мова.
Я така вау, тому що я розумію, що я такого не говорю, бо ми західняки, тобто як пішло, там якісь поля,
в нас дуже багато суржику і відповідно а ось літературна і чітка мова тому є це та це
зразу відчуваєте це так захоплююче якраз особливо які вчать просто і це ж друга якби
получається анексна перша тому друга друга так дійсно да бо вона літературна так я виріс вирісла
в Одесі бабці прабабці всі в мене коріння болгарське і там звісно дійсно ну не було української
мови але я пам'ятаю свою школу я донька військового і я бувала в тих місцях де були і села де не було
зручностей де не було нічого і звісно завжди це була російська мова і всі протоколи і навіть
коли ми переїхали я теж я пам'ятаю в 4 класі була також в селі в мене були якщо пам'ятаю тоді
це були олімпіади по мовам я їздила і займала перші місця української мови я займала перші
місця і це в мене що є це від від мого вчителя вона підписана на мене на фейсбуке Олена Петрівна
дай Боже її здоров'я вона каже Лана я коли почула а вона моя вчителька української мови і вона
каже Лана я коли почула що ти починаєш потрошки десь внедряти українську мову каже ти така молодець
Що ще просто супер, клас, дійсно супер.
Тому дякую велике, мені це дуже подобається.
Десь я затикю, десь я приходжу, десь щось пояснюю.
Але на майбутнє я вважаю, що я зможу.
Чого не зможу? Зможу, звісно.
Ми стільки все пережили, боже, чужі країни, чужі...
Туди переїхали, там нас хитало, там нас штовхало,
там опору теряли, контакт з собою теряли.
Все було. Що ж ми з мовою не з... Це не принципово.
Не принципово. Вибачаю за свої ось ці а-а-а і десь переходи.
Десь мені... Якщо брати наукову термінологію,
і як я навчаюсь когнітивно-поведінковий психотерапевт,
то оці когнітивні упередження, вони дуже важкі на українській мові.
Дякую. Настя, ви хотіли щось сказати? У нас є хвилиночка ще нашої перерви, закінчується зараз.
Хотіла по поводу язика дополніть теж, тому що я теж поняла, почему я не можу хорошо перейти на український.
Потому що, когда уходиш в глубину, потому що я чувствую, проживаю, і глубину только могу на русском донести.
і перестав нахайнути ну когда просит а бывает наоборот да щас сталкиваешься с тем что ты не
можешь подобрать слово на русском ну ты знаешь как его сказать красиво украинского яйца зависание
на служище скажу что мы тоже живем в украине с четырех лет например я до 8 класса была освобождена
українського язика є історія дякую дякую велике так повертаємося до нашого робочого
процесу дякую велике дякую що ви знову тут що в нас настільки класний сьогодні вайб в мене
день у вас вечір я розумію десь дітки десь пізно але але і дійсно я запишу медитацію
я ж аж включився на це але ну це прям ваш ну це смачно однозначно дякую так ну що ж
що ж виходимо на демо-версію виходимо на нашу демо-версію Василь що я хочу від вас
що я хочу демо-версія у нас буде буквально там до 10 хвилиночок щоб ми встигли і дати
Зв'язок
Повернутися собі
Я хочу
Щоби
Ти
Твоя завдання
Тільки ділитися
Просто ділитися тим, що в тебе є
Я буду поряд з тобою
Я буду тут
Я буду тебе дуже уважно слухати
І
Майже нічого
Не говорити
Добре?
дякую велике тож всі хто не спостерігачі вимикайте будь ласка камери всі хто є спостерігачами
слухайте уважно так спостерігачі не коментують спостерігачів тільки уважно слухають
Тож, чим ти хочеш сьогодні поделитися?
Якщо йти взагалі, так цікаво, першу практику я пропустив, бо я тільки прийшов і підігрів їсти,
і ви пішли в практику тоді, коли в мене вже було їсти підігрітою, я поняв, що ні, і я важливіший.
В другій я просто виговорився, а в третій, напевне, зараз, це буде моя глибинна перша,
Хочеться піти в глибину, для чого я створив і створюю зараз собі державну роботу, я не знаю, для чого, для відстрочки, але вона займає багато ресурсу і тяне багато енергії.
Ну тобто я є майстром виробничого навчання з 8 до 5, і там десь відносно перерви все решта приділяю увагу на консультування.
Проте в напрузі, що хтось може зайти, хтось може подзвонити. Тобто мої клієнти про це, звісно, що знають, вони погоджуються або беруть на вечір.
Але зараз я стикнувся з чимось, зі збільшенням кількості клієнтів. У мене все менше часу на себе коханого і на мою донечку.
І взагалі на бути, на просто бути в режимі тому, в якому я зараз маю, а я маю такий, ну, за рік я виріс дуже сильно, але і виросли мої фінансові зобов'язання.
І оце все в комплексі. Мені ця робота дає відстрочку, зараз мені пригадується для прикладу, що мама мені дала мінус 10, в шлюбі я мав плюс 10, а зараз я зрозумів, що я на плюс 100 хочу.
І чому я захоплювався шлюбом, який був, бо плюс 10 це плюс 10 тисяч відсотків. І зараз я розумію, що ця робота під час війни це знову ж таки плюс 10.
Але я десь починаю формувати ціль, щоб мій прямий навик, як психолога, як коуча, як ментора, як наставника, був вигідний комусь на такій роботі, хто може дати мені відстрочку.
І основний дохід, який перекриватиме базовий мінімум плюс фінансову дельту, там, тисячу-дві доларів, давався саме з цієї роботи, і все решта я вже брав скайфу з вільності.
І моїм інсайтом було те, що ця робота давала мені структуру.
Я, вроді би, до відпустки останньої, коли в мене не було сесії за сесіями, я міг час тратити просто.
Зараз відбулася моя моя відпустка двохмісячна, і я побачив, що я вже чітко,
по-перше, вже кількість клієнтів більша, і вже чітко за графіком, і за собою я можу.
Тобто, що я став ще більш дисциплінованіший, що я став, ну, тобто, зараз чітко у мене час, який повністю витрачений на нуль, напевне, може відсотків 8-10.
І це, типу, десь і так тільки мозок пробує хоч чуть-чуть, просить, що ви подихали, бо лани нема на екрані.
Все, тепер ми двоє на екрані, да, граємо далі, і чуть-чуть є вилетів, але це було сидомо, бо все одно перевернуло увагу, і я розумію, що зараз я готовий до самостійного, зрілого, дорослого життя, і я
хочу створити умови лайту, хоча теж, якщо рівняти минулий рік на моїй роботі, ті самі, два-три тижні було пекельних, завдяки яким я і пішов в психологію,
вчитися в магістратуру,
чуть не пішов психологом в це училище.
І зараз я теж аналізував
перші 2-3 тижні вересня.
Тобто це енергія шуму,
енергія переналаштування.
І я вичікував.
І зараз, вроді би, от від сьогодні,
там сьогодні я цілий день відпочивав.
То на озеро пішов, то в хамам,
то в зал, при тому, що я офіційно був на роботі.
І навіть трусики собі встиг купити,
так як Лана оце почула, побачила.
і погуляв з дочкою, але цьому прийшло те, що вчора я поняв, що баста, я втомився, я хочу відповідь, от після Юлії, от іде і тепер, і не свідомо, я сьогодні це створив, цей відпочинок, і навіть оце в
иговарювся, але моя глибина хочеться, або термінову миру, і свободи повністю від вістрочки, і плюс я розумію, що там я не маю свого ком'юніті, є учні, яким я трошки можу дати,
Ну теж, якщо там зараз, вони захлинаються, вони не готові до цього.
Типу, коли я їх щитую, коли вони хочуть збрехати і не мають змоги навіть, т.д. і т.п.
Бо фактично є все і цей.
Але і нема людей, з яких я можу притулитись і побути в одній енергії.
Тому що було, певне, раз відчуття, коли я до півшостої був на тусовці випускного лідерської програми на високих енергіях.
А в восьмій ранку я вже перетнув поріг роботи, коли я не встиг нейтралізувати енергію, я відчую, як ніби в мене все провалилось.
Я не ставив це за ціль, але зробив крок в то приміщення, і я ніби делейтнувся, типу, о, і я тоді відрозумів, наскільки я зливався.
Ну, от і такий от в мене саме запис, ну, зрозуміти навіть на чому вже, а де і як я можу створити свою свободу.
Спочатку фізичну ще більшу, а потім фінансову.
І просто ахоєнно летіти, літати, кайфувати, і далі вже йде створити сім'ю, відносини, і бути щасливим. Амінь.
Клас, клас, супер. Це було дуже емоційно. Клас.
Є щось, що ти можеш додати до того, що іменно ти хочеш, коли говориш про свою свободу?
Знаєш, десь абстрагуюсь від того, що ти говориш, тому що зараз десь частково накочуються сльози на очі.
Просто хочете собі поспівчувати, дати собі емпатії і сказати, що я молодець, в умовах, коли під час війни найбільша травма, розлучення і все решта, я створив себе і на кінець-то почав себе вибирати і
зливати енергію в себе, а не тільки в когось.
Тому от десь просто хочеться, щоб мене так 25 людей обійняло і дало цю теплоту, і просто в цьому розплистись, побути в кайфі, на солоді.
І тиждень, коротше не буду зараз створювати вакобрази, бо можуть мене по-різному видалити життя на тиждень.
Тиждень відпочити десь, десь от ось так. Просто принаймні розумом відпочити, щоб достатньо було коштів, достатньо було часу.
І точно не було когось, під ким я. Тобто я хочу вийти з найму. Поки що як такого без найму я не знаю.
Так, отут я сам в себе в наймі в тому, але є паралельно то, що тяне найм, де я маю підлаштовуватись.
І це якраз і моя адаптивна дитина, яка підлаштовувалась під всіх і вся я.
І зараз вона прям дихаючи свободу, вона навіть в училище адаптувала під мене зараз.
Тому що люди там в шоці, наскільки, ну, те, що я в хорошому сенсі слова там маю.
І навіть цей, але, коротше, я знову пішов до якихось нагород.
Просто хочеться тиші, спокою, відпочинку, масажу, сну, хамаму і друзі.
Клас.
Василь, нас тут 28.
28 людей.
І я хочу зараз, щоб ми всі
тебе обійняли.
Прямо обійняли.
Ми обіймаємо.
Обіймаємо кожен.
Бачиш?
Побач, побач, скільки
сердечок до тебе.
Це все тобі.
Ти сказав 20.
Нас 28, Василь.
Я хочу, щоб ти це
зараз відчув.
Просто відчуй, тепло-тепло, це все для тебе, бо ти дійсно цього заслуговуєш, клас.
Включається бунт і я не хочу заслуговувати, я хочу просто мати.
Ти це вже маєш?
Так.
Давай, так інтерпретуємо. Ти це маєш?
Я це маю, однозначно.
Клас.
Дякую. Це смачно.
Хочу повернути тобі.
Повернути, що ти на початку говорив.
Ти коли розказував про всю цю глибину, всю цю історію,
Ти так класно. Я відчула просто, коли казав за донечку. Ось такі жести були просто. В мене склалося відчуття, що ти, от я все, я все, от там, де є плюс 10, я все, ось воно, ось тут воно. Це так відч
увалось.
Я дуже відчула те, що ти говориш, що є потреба зараз піти на ці умови, бо ти чітко знаєш.
І твої рухи, ось ці, були чітко спрограмовані і показуючи те, що ти знаєш, заради чого ти це робиш.
Це було відчутно, коли ти говорив про цю стратегію, і коли ти відчув цей інсайт про умови, про те, що в тебе все вже вийшло, але тобі дійсно треба зараз наразі підлаштуватися.
Там була трошечки печаль
Там було печально
Бо ти потім
Трошки пізніше
Дві-три хвилинки
Ти сказав, що в мене
Ось цей супротив
Бо я мав підстроюватися
Там, там, там, там
І пішло
І це показує, що ти багато
Де підстроювався
І тому ми всі
28 чоловік, тебе обіймаємо
бо ось це, це багато
і коли так ти загинаєш
я розумію, що там це і на пальцях
можна було ніг
загинати, де ти підстроював
підлаштовувався
це було дуже відчутно
також ти з таким натхненням
класно розказував
про відпочинок
про те, що ти зміг, про те, що у тебе знайшовся час.
І ти сказав, я зрозумів.
І ось ти також відкинувся, це знаєш, я побідіць, я переможець, бо я зміг.
І знаєш, що я тобі скажу?
Ти зможеш ще раз.
І ще не раз ти зможеш так.
І ти будеш королем, бо ти зараз вже відчуваєш себе так.
І я хвалю тебе за це.
Ти вже себе отак відчуваєш.
І коли є питання, яке в тебе встало,
що я хочу свою свободу, я хочу ось цю організувати,
я хочу це зробити, я хочу знайти час,
в відповіді в твоїй невербаліці щитувалося,
що ти знаєш вже, як це зробити.
Ти вже знаєш, як це зробити наразі.
Бо ти є впевнений і твої очі тебе віддавали, видавали твою впевненість.
Мене ти не обманюш, Шеті.
Я й не старався.
Це було вже в твоїх очах.
Тому я безмежно тобі дякую за те, що ти відкрився.
Я тебе обіймаю.
Я сподіваюся, що наразі в тебе в впевненості не плюс 10, а плюс 100.
В мене спокою на плюс 100.
В цій впевненості, напевне, в мене вже давно-давно на плюс 1000, скажімо так.
А от спокою було менше.
А зараз ці обійми, ці відчуття, ця емпатія, це те, що мене почули, я почутий.
Мені співдіють, тому що мені на роботі багато співдіють, але інколи є момент, там де, ну, вовше нема проблем, але їх роблять, ось так, і там мене розйобає, тому що для чого, ну, але це інше.
І отут оця почутість, от чому я так до дитини своєї відгукуюсь, тому що саме чи напевне через свою дитину я зцілював внутрішнього себе, маленького Василька, перших років вісім, і давши їй багато, аж
тепер останній рік я вже даю як зрілий тато, який може бути і поганим, і хорошим, бо до того я тільки хороший був.
І це все в комплексі, найвосновніше це мене почули і мені дали себе, оце ще певне найбільше, ти дала мені себе, кожен із вас дав себе, і це напевне той вчинок, який по-справжньому, крім моєї дочки,
ніхто мені не давав з дорослих, а з дочки ссати її я не хочу, я її беру як тільки дочку, скажімо так.
Можливо, були друзі десь моментами, але мій турбулентний ріст відкидав їх, бо різні вібрації, різні енергії. Я ріс, ріс, ріс, ріс, ріс, ріс. І весь час в мене оця турбулентність. А зараз я отут відч
уваю себе навіть грубше. Тобто навіть якщо з тобою, мені не треба нікуди рости.
Тобто з тобою я окей, і тобі не треба рости, і т.д. і т.п.
І оця рівність, відчуття рівного, воно для мене таке сильне.
Бо тоді я не хочу нікуди бігти, я вже є. Достатньо. Все.
Ось так. Ти вже є. А тепер плечики опускай.
Опускай, так. Опускай руки. Опускай.
Ти коли говорив, то опускай, опускай, ти вже є, тебе вже достатньо, ти в контакті з собою.
І маленький Василь, десь рочків до восьми.
Я більш ніж впевнена, він зараз теж лікує.
Ой, ще як.
Тому дякую собі, тобі, і вам, і Богу за те, що я тут сьогодні прожив.
Не очікував.
Дякую. Дякую.
Далі більше. Далі крепше. Міцніше.
Тримціння в голосі. Ось тут.
Це прорив. І ти його сьогодні прям проривав.
І це було відчутно. Десь тут тримціло.
Дякую тобі. Обіймаємо.
Дійду до мене.
Іду.
Дожилися, обіймаємося з чемп'ютерами.
Я приїду в Британію, і ми це повторимо. Обіцяю.
Дякую велике. Боже, дякую вам за ваші салюти.
Повертаємося. Повертаємося. Я аж прям розчервонілася.
Дякую.
Дякую, дякую. Дякую великим.
Дякую за вашу присутність. Люди добрі. Дякую, бо Василю дійсно нас 28-27. Дякую за ваше серденько. Дякую за те, що ви віддавали, коли це було дуже потрібно. Дякую за вашу присутність, бо ви класні,
ви міцні.
Ви тут, ви в позиції були коучі, я це бачила, я це відчувала.
Дякую вам велике. Дякую.
Зворотній зв'язок, Василю, давай послухаємо, що там наші спостерігачі нам сьогодні скажуть.
Клас, клас, клас.
Так, дякую Василю за це представлення, виступ, виступ, да, тобто за цю щирість було класно, да.
Було класно спостерігати за емоціями людини, яка спостерігає це.
Це було щось нове.
Єдине слово, яке ти сказала два рази, це відпочинок.
Повторила про тому, що говорила.
І дуже багато було зацепків в тебе реакції, зв'язаного з відпочинком.
Коли Василь проговорив, у тебе тіло дуже сильно реагувало.
Зразу пішла посмішка на слово «їсти».
Прямо зразу.
Бо я ще не снідала.
Організм це показав я їла тільки шокуратку
от на Слава Донечка була реакція теж посмішка і головою ти що зробила я так я розбираю
каракулі би я писав кайф-вільність була реакція весь час в принципі отак от головою підтакувала
це було перманентного протягом всього я кажу що що змінювалося в процесі так так так і тут
об щось змінилося об щось змінилося тебе зачепило знову офіційно на роботі щось тебе там тригернуло
там щось було потім знову був відпочив і тебе прям знову знову включило так на трусі що Василь купив
там була топ-реакція я думаю це просто розрив шаблону був от тебе тригернули ти прямо що схилилися коли він
сказав що він бачить як учні збрехати ну учні що не можуть збрехати прямо таке ні ні ні я не согласен
потім перший раз в діалозі ти сказав слово так коли він сказав створити свободу до цього діалог
був ноль просто і створити так далі йдемо знову єсть коли він захотів обнімашок дуже різко
Ти йому дала це через просвіт, через камеру, зразу пішов контакт візуальний.
У мене було бажання ще обійматися, якщо б були всі в аудиторії, я скажу, десь на лекції, офлайн.
Я реально думаю, що не я одна, а ми би всі, коли Василь говорив про 20, так, Наталя, так, бачу, про 20 чоловіків, ми би всі підійшли і всі би об'їняли,
бо коли людині це потрібно і вона про це говорить, треба прям давати, прям дати, з тебе не убудять, а людині буде просто неймовірно.
і тобі плюс 100 це прийде, плюс тисяча, бо тобі буде теж класно бути дав цій людині зараз.
Тому я захотіла прям різко обійняти комп.
Я продовжую тему вчорашньої лекції трошки. Ви вчора про Оргію говорили.
А, так у вас було хлоп, так ви продовжуємо.
Ви підрізно викутали.
Ми не доповлялися, я не знаю про що.
готуємося зразу 11 місць на підготовку так пішли більше руки голову руфі головою
тіпа да-да-да ну якщо вони були перманентно невеликі то після обнімашок
ти наблизилась і більше рухали головою так на щось була реакція і не можу розібрати свій почерк
був супротив на слово підстроюватися теж щось там були і весь цей діалог був один період в
діалогі коли ти повторила слово це було відпочинок тобто всі слова ти говорила говорила говорила
тільки слово відпочинок десь повторила два рази єдине слово на якому тобі виникло тримтіння в
голосі от це то що я заміту дякую дякую велике я дуже імпатична людина і для цього я часто
використовую супервізії тому що я дуже відчуваю людину я відчуваю коли в неї тримтить тримтить
голос, я відчуваю, коли вона хоче заплакати,
я відчуваю її сльози, я
відчуваю це
через екран, і коли я це відчуваю,
мені хочеться теж разом
з ним теж поплакати,
затримцити і обійняти.
Але я розумію в цьому моменті, що я
є коуч, що в мене є коуч-позиція
і що маю я триматися.
Дякую велике, Юрій, за розбір.
Дуже тобі
дякую. Хочу почути,
так, Аня, бачу, хочу
почути зараз, як ви
побачили, друзі, чи
вдалося, що вдалося
зробити. Звісно, що вдалося.
Вдалося зробити нашу демо-сесію.
Вона була дуже потужна.
Хочу, щоб ви для себе
з позиції, як
я візьму це для себе,
я візьму, я розумію про цю тишу,
я розумію про, що мені робити.
Я більш, ще більш,
у третій раз ще більше закріпляю
і розумію, що мені брати з собою.
Так? Ось цей
коментар хочу почути зараз.
Анечка, так, ми в нас не так багато часу будемо, щоб і други могли висловитися, так, Аня?
У мене, да, коментарий не стосовно вашого запиту. Одною не послышалось,
ли действительно так було, що ви задали вопрос Василию, про свобода,
коли він говорив о свободі, і ви спросили, а що про тебе свобода, какая она?
Так, якого не було, але було якось активне слушання, але в то же время це був такий коментарий з випросом.
Так, це був випрос, вам не послышалось, коли він вже закінчив. Василь на той період вже закінчив, він сказав, в мене все, і як тільки я почула, що все, перед тим, ніж дати свій зв'язок, свою обратну
зв'язку,
Я дійсно хотіла розширено спитати одним реченням, що таке більше про свободу.
Тобто це можна?
Звісно, можна уточніть, звісно, можна уточніть.
Чому? Тому що, об'ясню, мені не вистачило, мені було недостатньо.
Тобто, я вам говорив багато в початку і про свою роботу, чому вимушений, чому там, чому там, там, там.
І коли перейшов такий вконець, в мене запит такий і коротко, бам-бам-бам, видав і закінчив.
І цього мені не вистачило.
Я його услышала, але мені не вистачило, що б він хотів.
І тому я задала це питання чітко туди, де мені не вистачало, щоб він хотів більше.
І ось про цю свободу я задала це питання.
Щоб не раскручивати його дальше, а вот в самый конец, де он сказав, що я хочу,
тому що, що я хочу, он сказав дуже коротко, і мені хотілося слухати чуть більше,
що він ще більше хоче, де там ще чуть-чуть більше, розкрутити, щоб дати вот эту обратну связь,
і то, що він хоче, вже усилить йому і підтвердити, що у нього вже є ці відповіди, він знає, як це зробити.
Друзі, колеги, чи є ще коментарі стосовно нашої демо-версії?
Добре, добре, дякую.
Окей, окей, чи всім було приємно слухати? Скажіть, будь ласка, дякую, дякую, дякую велике, так, всім було приємно слухати, клас, клас, супер, супер.
У мене, до речі, була ця штука, похожа до Каті.
Типу, я виключив все слухання, я практично його не чув, десь відчував, типу, вайп, коли бачив в тебе емоції, я слухаю, а що тут?
Типу, мозк ніби відтворює це назад.
Але в основному я був якраз фокусуваний на реакціях.
От було прикольно, наскільки інформаційний шум можна відключити, коли у тебе увага сфокусовано на чомусь іншому.
Так, так, дійсно так.
Ну що ж, ми сьогодні, я правильно розумію, що ми завершуємо,
бо я з цим часом не дуже регулююся, в мене 11.49,
і я знаю, що ми закінчимо 12.20 якраз.
Так, ми закінчуємо.
Сьогодні ми розібрали, давайте повторимося.
Мені так дуже приємно сьогодні ось ця така плотна праця,
що я хочу, щоб ви мали достатньо часу для свого фідбеку на сьогоднішній день.
Тож ми розібрали, що таке активне слухання на глибинному рівні.
Ми це розібрали прямо в діалогах, на практиці.
Чому внутрішня тиша коуча створює простір для клієнта?
Ми сьогодні розібрали також небезпеку поверхневого слухання,
щоб не слухати тільки з поверхні та запитання без інтерпретації.
Роль тіла як інструмента.
Ви маєте таке невеличке домашнє завдання.
Фільм дійсно цікавий.
Подивіться, рекомендую.
Роль тіла як інструмента слухання та маркера зміну клієнта.
Як невербальні сигнали формують довіру і відкритість.
Бачите, як невербаліка, як ця тиша сьогодні визвала у багатьох
такі класні,
дуже чуйні такі емоції.
І зараз
я хочу переключитися на цю
найпотужнішу
в кінці...
Закінчуємо о 21-й
тежла на повну часу.
Я... А!
Тепе тільки 12-та година,
а ми ще на 9 годин лишаємось.
Питань нема.
Да, да, да.
Ні, я маю поснідати.
Дякую.
Отпустіть на завтрак і все.
Так, звісно. Ми навіть можемо замовити
тобі завтрак. Скажи, де ми
замовимо зараз завтрак? Що організуємо?
І убіть замовимо.
Я вам скажу таку історію
не по темі. У нас трошечки
часу. Мене вчора відмовилися
обслуговувати, тому що не знають
англійської мови.
Не відмовились, а просто засмущались
і ушли в закат.
Люди в ресторані, обслуживаючи
персонал. Я подхожу, вони...
Я знімала на відео сама себе, думаю, так, що мені тут робити?
А я хочу тільки пальчиком тикнути, я хочу цей врап з рибою чи з м'ясом,
а вони кажуть, я кажу, ви розмовляєте трошечки на англійською?
Кажу, це не проблема.
А вони просто кажуть, ні-ні-ні, і пішла, і пішла.
Я кажу, hello.
Також, так, про замовлення.
Добре, повертаємося.
Рефлексія. Скажіть, будь ласка, що змінилося у вашому слуханні сьогодні? Що сьогодні ви відкрили нового для себе? Що ви побачили в цій тиші, в цій неймовірній тиші? Що ви для себе побачили? Скажіть,
поділіться. Я знаю, я в Мексике. Я зараз в Мексике. У нас компанія є срочний алерт.
British Airways, я ще продолжаю
роботати кризисним психологом, тому що
я наразі в Мексиці
в Сан-Моіс-Потосі
місто називається.
І так
мене часто кидають.
Десь я літаю,
десь я там.
Ось, по всьому світу.
Так, Настя Віноградова,
поділитися так.
Я поняла, почему
У мене дуже комфортно, тому що тут одна з моїх важних цінностей –
іскрінність. Іскрінність просто присутствує в полному об'ємі.
Тому мене дуже комфортно.
Що забираю сьогодні з собою?
То, що ще раз себе підтвердила, що я більше через чувства.
У мене дуже більша емпатія, і я через чувства йду.
Чаще всего і невербаліка мені легше дають засчитуватися, і включати мозг іногда і не треба, і це може бути навіть сила і плюс.
Тобто вивожу це в себе в помощники більше, ніж як раніше я стеснялась цього, задавлювала, хотіла через дару спускати.
Клас, клас, це супер. Що це вам більше дало, розкроєте що?
Больше спокійства і уверенність, тому що коли йдеш через чуства, думаю, треба включити мозг і тут ж ще все проаналізувати.
І т.е. я задавлювала це і теряла контакт, могла і вилітати.
А сегодня я именно убедилась і почувствовала, що мені це в допомогу і в плюс, і це не треба отрицати.
І, дійсно, якщо відключається мозг і я через чуства чувствую більше клієнта і розумію його, і можу дати результату,
то це, як би, навіть іграє мене на руку.
Так, звісно.
Це не так, що емпатія мене дуже мешається.
І усвішала, що вона не мешається.
Наверно, чаще придеться, дійсно, потім ходити на супервізи,
тому що є таке пропускання.
Я і плачу теж з клієнтом, так краткою витираю слези.
А іноді і не краткою.
Тут важна опора в себе, контакт з собою.
Просто взяти це як моє сила, інструмент, і необязательно включити мозку, так, відключи чувства, быстро через мозку прогоняйте.
Нужна действительно опора, що да, я це чувствую, да, я це понимаю.
Принимаю.
Принимаю, і тоді сталося легче. Просто всталося на своїх містах.
Так, так.
Благодарю за цей день.
Дякую большое, дякую.
Дякую вам за активну роботу сьогодні, дякую.
Александр Волков, ви там молчите,
але я вас потім все равно спрошу.
Потім.
Зараз у нас є руки.
Ага, добре, дякую.
Наталічка Нотса, так.
Я почну з тиші.
Я колись раніше, може комусь буде знайома,
робила таку практику, як Коан, здається, вона називається,
коли п'ять хвилин виговорюєш свій запит,
а людина сидить навпроти,
чи п'ять, чи десять хвилин сидить навпроти,
і вона просто на тебе дивиться, беземоційно дивиться.
І то так тяжко було,
бо спочатку говориш наїжджені, заїжджені фрази,
говориш, говориш, говориш,
а потім справді на останніх трьох хвилинах
виходить справді та суть, яка ховалася всередині.
Тому тиша для мене, сьогодні це сила,
я про це прям згадала,
І будь-який інструмент, який беру в коучингу, я розумію, наскільки круто,
це для сім'ї, оце мовчання, активне слухання і так далі.
Це дуже-дуже сильний інструмент.
І з клієнтами ми все одно такі стримані, тому що особливо,
якщо це перші десь знайомства, ми стримані, а в сім'ї ми вже розкриті,
відкриті, ми один одного знаємо.
І коли тут вже на автоматизмі ввести ці якості,
то відповідно, включити в собі ці якості,
то відповідно розумію, що в професійній експертній діяльності
воно буде давати ще більш масштабніші результати.
Що я для себе сьогодні нового взяла?
Те, що мені складно щитувати по рухах.
Бо я іноді можу слухати людину, я можу навіть на неї не дивитися,
але по її тембру, по цьому всьому я її відчуваю.
І оце моя така сильна сторона.
І сьогодні побачила, що все-таки треба ще збільшувати свої можливості в тому,
щоб вчитися і справді дивитися фільми, читати книжки для того,
щоб і це стало також моєю сильною стороною.
Тому велике дякую.
Сьогодні реально було дуже потужно, дуже живо.
Ось така прям жива була, був живий ефір.
І мені сподобалось. Дякую вам велике.
Дякую. Розширюйтеся, розширюйтеся.
Цей фільм, про який я кажу, вам може бути дуже корисним.
Дякую.
Дякую, я записала.
За роботу.
Дякую.
Юлія Свірідзюк.
Що забираєте з собою, скажіть?
Багато чого.
Хотіла почати з того, почула колись від когось твою фразу поговорити об когось.
Коли хтось нічого не говорить, абсолютно нічого.
Просто ти говориш об когось.
І це про те, що сам себе чуєш, і чуєш по-іншому, не так, як десь шумом, як ми це завжди звикли.
Ми кудись там біжимо, праця, ще щось, а ми себе чуємо по-іншому зовсім, без цього шуму.
А просто чітко вже себе, свої думки, чого хочеться, куди йдемо і так далі.
І дуже круто, сьогодні я якраз таки поговорила об когось, або мені сьогодні якраз таки було потрібно також вивелити.
І просто, щоб ніхто нічого не казав, просто послухайте мене і все, я там далі розберусь.
Тому дуже дякую за сьогоднішній день, нові усвідомлення, кайф і сьогодні так дуже пролуців швидко час, ми постійно спілкувалися, це прям дуже-дуже правда. Дякую вам.
Дякую, дякую, дякую велике, дякую Юлечка, посилаю. Дійсно, поговорити об когось це дуже класно, дуже класно.
Для цього ми і є в цій професії.
Коли можемо ми поговорити і коли об нас хтось говорить.
Дякую.
Ірина.
Для мене такі інсайти, що сила в тишині і слова бувають зайві.
Сьогодні вони набрали свого реального змісту, сенсу, розуміння і такої величини.
Тому що мені завжди здавалося, що коли сидиш з людиною, ну і мовчиш її, навіть якщо ти уважно слухаєш, ти в присутності,
що треба якось підтримати. Тобто підтримка, мені здавалося, що вона буде в словах.
Сьогодні я розумію, що слова можуть бути займами. Можна, якщо в офлайні, тоді обняти.
Це буде сильніше, ніж слова. І дати цей час для висвобождення і щоби виговорила все.
і тоді вже це класно якраз отут і емпатія імпатичні відносини харизматія та оці всі
тобто якраз і будується що кажеш а на чому а як і от таке тонке-тонке така тонка лінія якби йде
тому ось це розуміння є тому що і витримка в цій постаті бо мені завжди та ні то що треба
Можу сказати, треба дати, треба аж підтримати.
А сьогодні знаю, що це буде те, що потрібно людині, власному персоналу.
На прикладах. Дякую.
Дякую велике.
Мені прийшла зараз думка така, ви знаєте, метафору, ми як, ми коучі, ми як шовкопряди.
Не знаю, відгукаються вам чи ні, але для мене, знаєте, шовкопрят, це, не на українській мові, дуже класно звучить, шовкопрят.
Це просто про оце паутиня шовкове, яке ми будуємо, воно невидиме.
В стосунках з нашим співбесідником, з нашим коучі, з нашим клієнтом.
Оце паутиня, для мене, ось цей шовкопоряд, як метафора того, якими коучі, якими тендітно, якими тендітно можемо і вміємо вибудувати ці стосунки з клієнтом.
ось отак от і виблизькувати просто на на сонечці дякую дякую велике сподіваюся вам
відгукується ви заберете з собою Олена Сідик як ви що заберете з собою я взагалі хочу сказати
що я так на зустріч прийшла трошки втомлена але настільки сьогодні було класно настільки живо
настільки щиро, що проминуло 4 години, я ще дві просиділа, якщо чесно. Думаю, що мене підтримують в цьому.
Що збираючи з собою? Оця остання сесія — це просто вау в тому сенсі, наскільки ви проявили свою імпатичність з цими обіймами.
Чомусь я собі в ролі коуча такого не дозволяв і зараз я бачу, що можна інакше і це прям вразило, тому що я зараз кажу, а в мене аж в урахі бігають. Дуже дякую за сьогоднішню зустріч, це прям клас,
мені дуже сподобалося.
Клас. Дякую. Про обійми. Дякую велике за ваш відео. Про обійми скажу тільки те, що є кордони. Ми розуміємо, де ці кордони. Ми розуміємо, що хоче клієнт зараз. І ось ці кордони, вони в нас є, вони виб
удовані.
Да Василь ви добавите додадете Ну переді мною була Валерія я не до цього я просто кінцівку ще один сайт
добре так дякую дякую бачу да так Валерія потім Олександр
Хочеться поділитися і значально поблагодарити Василию.
Василий, я прям благодарю тебе, що ти не уступив мене сьогодні місто на демо-сесії.
Тому що в течінні часу, коли ти говорив, я почувствовала той момент,
що я хочу сама себе услышати в тому, чим хотілося поділитися.
Поэтому це було дуже круто.
Я вот сегодня забираю з собою тот инсайт,
що іногда нам кажется, що ми кому-то хочемо сказати,
але ми просто хочемо услышати себе.
Да, именно так, именно так.
Спасибо огромное, спасибо.
Александр, слушаємо вас, спасибо большое.
І затем Юлечка Петченко.
Да, привет.
А що мене треба сказати, що я забираю з собою?
Да, що вам було сьогодні? Я розумію, ви сьогодні заработаєте целий день. Я надію, ви там не в танчикі.
Не, у мене тут нету ігра. Не, я слушаю на сьогодні теж внимательно. По поводу того, що я забираю з собою. Ну, во-первых, класно, що напомнили про существування серіала «Теорія лжи», тому що я когда-
то його весь посмотрел, но тепер знову пересмотрю вже з новим взглядом, скажімо так.
По поводу того, щоб слушати і не задавати питання, це інтересно, так як у мене не було, але ми зашли, коли на практику, я там все-таки сильно полез з питаннями, перший раз, второй раз вже без питання
, просто сиділа, слушала і такий, ну, здержав в себе цю історію, щоб не почати накидувати, особливо, коли є какое-то рішення в конкретній голові, мені ж зразу і з рішеннями тянет.
А по поводу «смотреть», «изучать людей», у мене це з діття, що ли.
Я всегда люблю наблюдать за поведением людей і так далі.
У мене просто так получилось, що дедушка був начальником уголовного розыска,
і ко мене з діття прививали цю культуру.
Як следити за людьми, як следити за їх поведением, аналізувати і так далі.
Поэтому все, що связано з поведением людей, я люблю смотреть.
Очень часто.
Із-за цього мені навіть іногда знакомі робили зазначення,
що я порой дуже пристально наблюдаю за іншими людьми.
То есть, оно как-то есть у мене.
Вот.
Поэтому я не знаю, що ще сказати.
Буду пересматривать сериал, учиться не задавати вопросы там,
де не треба їх задавати.
А потім ще пересмотрю сесію і думаю, що-то нове для себе опять усвішую.
Отлично. Спасибо большое.
Спасибо.
Юля Печенка, я помню, що ви піднімали руку, по-моєму, в різний раз,
потім опустили руку.
Ви хотіли щось сказати?
Я сьогодні дуже не в своїх активностях,
але я старалась по максимуму бути присутнішою.
Поднімала руку, а потім у мене пропал питання,
коли ви порекомендували письмати фільм чи серіал,
ми повинні считати емоції.
І я думаю о тому, що коли люди грають,
наскільки це буде правдиво,
і наскільки ці емоції будуть дійсно соответствувати тому,
що вони чуствують, коли це гра.
Я заберу сьогодні з собою,
мені запомнилося дуже добре,
коли ви сказали, що чоловік,
який говорить, що це може бути нарциссискою,
якщо це растрійство.
Вже я хочу поблагодарити всіх участників,
і вас, Лана.
Мене дуже жаль, що я не могла сьогодні бути дуже активною,
але ви розкачали сьогодні прямо на максимум усіх.
І, знаєте, така енергія піднімалася дуже круто.
Оперше, я восхищаюсь тим, як ви все запомінаєте,
всіх запомінаєте, все запомінаєте.
Хто що піднял, навіть за мене, я там підняла на секунду руку,
ви вже побачили, запомніли.
Ну, я дивлюсь так за всіми.
Очень круто.
І активність, яку ви розкачали,
все максимально включені.
Я думаю, всі согласяться со мною.
Дякую, дуже круто. Благодарю вас.
Дякую. Дякую. Для мене це цінно. Дякую.
Дякую. Пам'ять тренується з годами.
Единственное, що я записувала, це тільки за Василием.
Телефон мой снимає все це час.
Дякую. Дякую.
Дякую.
Василий, добавляйте.
Я зараз прям візьму з собою те, що те, що я хочу, і воно в мене звисло в голові, я від нього не втечу. Чому? Тому що в середу, коли викладачі робили демо-версію для майбутніх студентів,
І там одна з глядачок зробила збір на своє навчання. І Юлія зарепустила. І саме тоді, на її прикладу, я захотів написати в наш чат, типу, народ, якщо б хтось знав, де є відстрочка і потрібен психолог
, коуч і т.д. і т.п., напишіть мені.
Ну я цього ще не зробив, бо я подумав, що зараз будуть відгуки за відгуками і одне-друге коментар перекриє. І не це. Планував після цієї сесії.
І коли я зараз усвідомлюю, що мій запит вже тут і тепер озвучений ротом, тоді, коли всі є в увазі.
І точно поле спрацює. І ось про це, що все, що мені потрібно, мені прийде, тільки довіряти собі і не то, що не втікати, а довіряти собі. І в цьому вся сила. Дякую.
Дякую велике. Я ж казала, що відповіді всі в тебе вже є.
Я ж сказала, що всі відповіді в тебе вже є.
Ти їх вже маєш. І ось вони.
Ти їх зараз озвучив.
Клас. Дякую велике. Це просто мощ.
Дякую. Супер. Клас. Дякую.
Ну що ж, я просто...
А, Оксаночка, бачу вашу руку. Давайте ще хвилиночка.
Я постараюсь быстро практичне, то, що возьму себе.
Вот це то, що ви напомнили про self-discovery, да?
Ответить, хто я?
То есть, коли, я так понимаю, коуч-ментор отвечає, хто я?
Ему легче искати опору, і, естественно, ему легче і тогда,
вот то, що підсветила Настя, коли недостаток знаний,
а хвати все не так просто, да?
То есть, вот эта опора, она поможет, вот эта емоціональність, включенность.
Дальше. Понравилось, що коуч слухає, як клієнт іщить себе.
Не просто він слухає, а він слухає, як клієнт себе іщить.
Іщить вот ці відповіди на свої ж питання.
І виходить, що ви Васильєю допомогли, йому він розкрывався і сам знаходив.
Дальше. То, що коуч не про те, що він зробив чи робив, а про те, що з цим буде робити клієнт.
Ось що буде робити клієнт Василий, ти молодец, ти будеш віддіхати і ти царь. Я тобі об цьому писаву. Возьму нехватка слов Оля Богданова підсвятила описання, несмотря на те, що якби, як знання, нач
итанність, але дійсно нехватка слов для описання стаєння человека.
То есть це, наверное, важливо не тільки для обучення, а важливо навіть конкретно для себе, будь то б ты коуч, будь то ти, і вообще в коммуникації с людьми для понимания.
І понравилось, що ти не просто слушаєш клієнта, ти создаєш тишину, тому що создання тишини – це і слухати, і сопережувати, і опору.
Все, всім понятно, що тут далі умнічати.
І, знаєте, Віталій, це НЛП, він тоді на лікції сказав ще таке,
що я так поверила в свого клієнта, що він поверил в себе сам.
Вот ви сьогодні це зробили на демо-версі, просто, ну, я не знаю.
Я вас благодарю, все.
Спасибо, спасибо.
Я не знаю, скільки треба сердец тут відправити.
Дякую, потім сердеця, я буду знімати, давайте потім.
Валерія Кличма.
Я дуже швиденько, щоб нікого не затримувати, бо п'ятниця вже в нас дев'ята, хоча можемо ще посидіти, та доланених дев'яти.
Я хочу подякувати за сьогоднішню зустріч, дійсно надихаюча, драйвова, щось згадується, щось по-новому чую.
І це все, знаєш, складається по поличках, якісь книжки доставляються, якщо говорити метафорично. Окремо хочу подякувати за сьогоднішню демо-сесію і Василю, в тому числі, в першу чергу, і тобі за цей
простір, вкотре запевнюють в тому, що сила цих демо-сесій в тому, що розбирають одного, умовно кажучи, проводять цим шляхом одного, а проходять всі.
Кожен щось своє в тому чує, відчуває, якісь свої сенси закладає, і це допомагає також знаходити відповіді всередині себе.
Бо я сьогодні на вашій демо була не зовсім прям спостерігачем, не слідкувала, як ти проводиш, а більше занурювалась в ті думки, про які в голос говорить Василь.
Сили тобі, я проходжу приблизно такий же шлях. В мене єдине, що немає оцього ускладнення з місцем роботи і певними умовами. Це тільки трішечки я в цьому виграю. Ми всі з тобою пройдемо цей шлях. Це
не так складно, як здається, сказала людина, яка тільки що сказала, що така сама ситуація, а я поруч.
Я думаю, Валерія, що ти за два дня відповідь на свій запит вже сьогодні почула,
бо ти вчора озвучувала чудесно про державну руку з роботи, також стабільну.
То я думаю, що твоє поле працює...
Воно все відбукується, все складається.
Обійняла кожного.
Дякую, дякую велике.
Друзі, дякую, колеги, дякую.
Ви такі класні, а от зараз можна, сердечки, я візьму телефон
І буду їх знімати, які ви класні в мене сьогодні
Дякую, дякую вам велике
Хочу подякувати не просто за ваші сердечки
А хочу подякувати за сьогоднішню вашу присутність
За те, що ви сьогодні такі класні
За те, що ви сьогодні так
Нічого далі буде більше
Бо теорія – це теорія
А коли практика – далі буде більше
Слайди – це слайди
Так? А ось коли є контакт, контакт з собою, опора з собою, опора в собі – це найважливіше.
Тому відпускаю вас і до зустрічі завтра.
Дякую.
Па-па!
Дякую велике.
Бай-бай!
Та ви не виходите!
Вона виходить!
До твоєї дев'ятої ще далеко, все окей.
Хеппі бірдей!
Ні, не хеппі бірдей!
Ми коли-то сиділи до 12 з Васілеєм.
Оооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооо
О-о-о! Вместо пяти почти десять часов. О, це тоже, це класно. Окей, хорошо. Друзі, пішла я завтракати. Ну добре, ну ладно, обламуй нас, іди. Приятного апетита! Отпустити!